um pass it around um pass it around
now oh all
right okay good enough thank
you good morning everyone welcome to
environment and
agriculture I'm a minute or two there we
go 10 o'clock according to my uh my
laptop get everybody
settled
I got
it good morning everybody Welcome to
environment and agriculture um
representative Bixby is handing out some
amendments and we have some other
documents going around
too but clock says 10:00 and we are got
a lot of work to do before between now
and noon so I'd like to get started and
I would like to have representative
Davis please lead us in the pledge of
allegiance aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all
thank you
everyone do want to remind my members
that
um if you're making a motion this
morning uh you will be the one writing
the uh committee report and I would like
to have those in as soon as
possible uh if you can't do it by the
end of the day uh when you before you
leave I'd like you to email it me this
evening if you need any of the forms
please let me know or let uh
representative Kwan
know so I'm going to open up our exec
session this
morning
and guess we'll wait for representative
dicksby because
we are opening up with HB
1293 relative to prohibiting the use of
certain fertilizers using
phosphorus
okay representative Bixby you may take
your
seat and I believe you have a motion to
offer
us thank you
so I would like to move on to pass with
Amendment
on uh
hb12 motion to okay I would like to make
a motion to adopt the amendment uh which
is somewhere
here uh yes uh Amendment uh z uh
224049 4H
uh to uh HB
1293 uh and uh you like to speak oh we
need a second I would be most pleased to
second that motion would you like to
speak to your your Amendment please I
would be happy to speak to my Amendment
so uh the amendment basically uh retains
the intent of the original bill but it
reorganizes it in order to fit better
into the structure of the chapter uh so
um in the original Bill uh everything uh
was added to uh section R RSA section uh
431 colon
4B uh and uh which is uh the section
that deals essentially provides the
regulatory Authority uh for um doing
registrations for um F phosphate
fertilizer that contains phosphate or
turt turf fertilizer that contains
phosphate um and uh 430
4314 B and also 4 a were put into law
back in 2013 with the intention of
reducing uh nutrient uh runoff into
water bodies and they those two uh
sections just regulate just provide the
Authority for registration and uh what
can be sold in the State uh so it wasn't
really the right place to put the uh a
lot of the information in that that came
in in uh the original version of 1293
because most of what 1293 uh does is it
provides the uh it
provides uh regulation of how uh
how fertilizer is applied to Lawns
rather than the registration and sale of
fertilizers
so uh what I did was I took the um I
took the new definitions that were in
the uh bill that was given to us I put
those into the definitions section of uh
431 which is 431 colon 3 and added some
more definitions that would be on necess
necessary in order to make the bill work
I also took out some of the definitions
that weren't
necessary uh so uh for instance um um Mr
uh uh so Eric uh satel from the Farm
Bureau uh mentioned that uh the
definition of uh of frozen ground wasn't
really necessary because that also
appeared in the um in the in the
language of the Bill of the statute
itself so you don't really need to
Define it twice
uh so
uh so uh what I've done is um
essentially
uh and and and looking at this just came
from
OLS five minutes ago so I didn't see
exactly I haven't had a chance to read
over what they did what it looks like
like what they did was they provided all
of
4313 with the new information in
um uh put into the spaces incorrect
alphabetical order with the old old
definitions there as well which is
actually kind of Handy
um so that's what's going on with the
definitions portion of it uh with uh in
let's see on page
okay definitions are a big part of this
bill so uh on page four uh
43 uh 431 uh colon
4A uh I
have um added the uh to the title of
that paragraph I've added uh the the
word Turf to make to make it clear that
uh this is uh this is just relevant to
what's going on to Turf it is not
relevant to any other agricultural
purpose uh so uh that that was something
that should have happened 10 years ago
when uh the bill was originally done but
it didn't uh and I did the same thing in
um in
431 uh colon 4B uh and the other changes
uh
in uh in 431 a are essentially just to
uh make the uh to to make the language a
little bit more consistent with what uh
the um with with app code def AFCO is an
organization that does definitions for
fertilizer and other nutrient amendments
and this this just makes it a little bit
more consistent with uh what would be
needed for uh uniformity across state
uh in uh 4B I uh added um I I changed
things to be uh to so uh the um there's
a appco definition for no phosphate
fertilizer that is different from what
we current what we have in current law
and it makes sense to use that uh that
um definition that is essentially un
form across all the states uh and uh so
the that re that afo definition has uh
no phosphate is being less than
05% phosphate rather than
um uh rather than
667 what which is what's in current law
and uh the
um and then uh for the fertilizer that's
intended for newly established and
repaired Lawns that would be what is um
considered a low phosphate fertilizer uh
at in the appco definitions so uh that
is um and the numbers there of the 0.25
pounds per th square feet uh or and um
per application and half a pound per
thousand square Fe feet per year that's
comes from the appco
definition
um
and then
um the next section is um the is a new
section which is application of
fertilizer uh to Urban Turf and Lawn and
urban Turf and Lawn is the appco term
that that's used for basically uh any
lawn that's not a golf course or a sod
farm and uh
so uh the first paragraph of that is
just making it um doubly clear that this
does not apply to sod farms and uh golf
courses as long as those um operations H
are are working within the best
management practices that are consistent
with what the department has on their
website um
and and I I talked with the uh a
representative of the Golf Course
Association and they
essentially uh put together their own
best management practices manual in
cooperation with the Department using
the Department's uh numbers and
terminology so uh so that's that is you
know that maintains the consistency and
they are happy with
that um
so
uh then we get into uh the meat of what
can and can't what the restrictions on
application are
um so
uh the any any fertilizer that is
applied to aan uh is uh has to be um one
of the ones that's defined within the
bill as a turf fertilizer uh and uh with
the appropriate purpose
uh and uh there's no application of uh
fertilizer shouldn't be applied during
heavy rain and uh the um I'm sticking
with the number that was in the original
bill which is uh two inches in 24 hours
and
um and uh the uh rather than saying what
the depth of uh frozen ground is it's um
with
in discussions with with various people
it sounded like just saying when the
ground is Frozen is
sufficient um and uh then um the other
thing is that fertilizer should not be
applied when turf grass is not actively
growing and that gets us around the
question of what should the dates be
because uh if we have a variation in
what the growing season is because you
know we suddenly get March where the
whole month is over 80 degrees then the
grass will start
growing
and and uh or conversely if we have a
April when the ground is still
completely Frozen we don't want to be
applying it even after April 1 so that
that was a a suggestion from Mr sautel
from the uh Farm Bureau that just um
having the uh having it linked to when
the when plants are growing is what
really is the the determinant um
and uh no application to impervious
surfaces and I uh if you go back to the
definitions impervious surfaces include
some things that you probably would
never apply fertilizer to like roofs I
just took that definition from the
shoreline protection act because I
didn't want to have
inconsistent um uh definitions in
different parts of of state law
um and uh if you accidentally spill it
then you need to re on an impervious
surface you need to remove it uh
immediately and either put it on the
target area or dispose of it
properly uh and
uh and I maintained the original bills
set back from a storm drain of 25 ft uh
and clarified the language there just
saying that no fertilizer should be be
deposited where it can enter the storm
drain
uh
and
uh consistent with uh the shoreline
protection act and the original Bill uh
there's a setback from Waters uh is 25
feet and that's as defined in the r that
that definition is also something that
is from the original
Bill and
uh then uh basically these restrictions
apply to anybody who's applying
uh fertilizer to Urban Turf and Lawn uh
whether it's a professional or a
homeowner or um uh yeah um and then the
next section is uh the public educ
education part the original Bill had
something about having it separated on
the store shelves uh so that there would
be a separate location for Turf
fertilizers with no low or no phosphor
phosphorus from other
fertilizers uh and that was uh people
generally didn't think that was a great
idea uh that it was overly prescriptive
and what's really important is making
sure that there are signs that let
people know uh what sort of a fertilizer
they should be applying to Lawns and
what the what the uh proper practices
are so um the key part here is is that
the department will Design signage that
uh basically addresses all of the
application restrictions that are in
this bill and uh some of the logic
behind it in terms of avoiding um
excessive fer fertilizer in water bodies
and what the dangers that of that could
be and then those those signs will be on
the department website as PDFs which
retailers
then
will download and print and post in
their fertilizer
areas uh
and
uh uh and that is so in terms of
enforcement no one's going to be going
around and checking up on people uh to
see if they're applying fertilizer
correctly we uh that that's just not
within either our capabilities or our
desires the key part of this bill in
terms of helping people uh do it
correctly are the signs that are going
to be in the fertilizer sections um in
in the stores so uh that public Ed
education is really key in terms of
making this bill work and that's the
amendment I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative
K thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
just looking at the definition of
enhanced efficiency
fertilizer and it say means lawn
fertilizer products so does that mean
that it will say for lawn use on the
product because I understand over in on
page
four uh section 2 line
15 uh no enhanced uh efficiency
fertilizer shall be you know at a single
application rate but I just want to make
sure that we're talking about fertilizer
that is labeled long fertilizer yes so
that definition comes straight from
appco and uh so and uh fertilizer
manufacturers look to the app code
definitions when they're putting
together their labels thank you thank
you represent sofikitis
please put your um
microphone just asking because we have
so many um uh substitutes here today
that the acronyms will will be uh given
in long form for them so they understand
what we're talking about sure going
forward yes yeah so uh so AFCO I can't
remember the exact name of it the exact
title it's but it's basically the a
National Organization made up of
Manufacturers and
researchers uh that figure out what the
appropriate um definitions and labels
are for uh soil Amendment products uh in
order to uh make sure that there's
consistency across States so um and I if
you really if you're desperate to know
what the what it actually stands for I'm
sure Mr Wyman can tell you but um I'm
not sure that we need
that okay represent
Penza I have the easiest question so um
the ACT shall take effect January 1st
2025 is there a reason re why we're
delaying it why we can't do this 60 days
out um I think that was that was what
was in the original bill and I did not I
didn't really think about that part uh
and I think that uh one of but one of
the things that that M that makes sense
with that is that um we we need to give
retailers enough time to become aware of
the law so that they'll know that they
need to be posting stuff follow up
follow up yeah I understood that because
in regards with having the PDFs
available for signage and things like
that I just thought that it's a long
time January 1 versus 60 days but that's
fine thank you any other comments we
ready to uh i' like to have the clerk
call the role for this uh
Amendment uh thank you madam chair we
are voting on adopting Amendment 20
2449 for Bill hb1 1293 FM representative
kraton hi representative coma yes
representative Moffett I representative
Davis yes representative Bean yes
represent kulan yes represent Brown yes
represent Penza yes represent smart yes
representative Bixby yes represent
sopus yes represent Duty yes repr Murray
yes representative Jam yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
NAB yes represent moris yes represent
bamin yes madame chair yes motion P the
amendment is adopted
20 uh now do I hear a motion to uh move
this otpa I'd like to move I'd like to
uh move hp1
1293 FN uh otpa with Amendment uh
[Music]
2024-the Bixby would you like to say
something about this uh I think the
discussion of the amendment pretty much
covered it so um thank you I I I would
like to say that I really appreciate uh
representative ball and all her
co-sponsors for bringing this bill in
because I think this is an important
thing to work on and representative
Bixby I would like to uh personally
thank you for all the work and time
you've put into this and speaking with
uh folks like Eric satel and U Mr Wyman
and other folks from uh Dees and so
forth I appreciate you getting all the
um brain power together to uh put
together a pretty um comprehensive and
well put together Bill thank
you um any
discussion then I see none
representative kto would you call the
role on this uh otpa motion thank you
madam chair we're voting on
HB
1293 with the amendment representative
kraton I representative coma yes
represent Moffet I represent Davis yes
represent Bean yes represent kulan yes
represent Brown yes represent Penza yes
represent smart yes represent Bixby yes
repres sopus yes represent Duty yes
represent Murray yes represent jamana
yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
moris yes represent bman yes Madam chair
yes
20 would you uh would anyone mind if we
put this on
consent okay put this on consent thank
you moving along to hb1
1294 um and representative Bixby or no
I'm sorry representative NAB I believe
you have a
motion
adopt microphone please you I move to
adopt the amendment to 1294 um and the
amendment
is thank you uh 2024
40487 I have
your um and do I hear a
second um Madam chair I second that
motion would you like to speak to your
Amendment representative
NAB well I I can I can speak to Okay
represent viby you can speak to the
motion so um so uh what this amendment
does is it uh replaces the entire bill
with uh a study committee and uh the
what became clear in the testimony was
that uh there was a real problem and the
solution that was presented in the
original Bill didn't really address the
real problem the real problem is that uh
the communities uh around Great Bay uh
and in the Great Bay Watershed uh and I
I think this may be also an issue for
other communities in other parts of the
State uh are having difficulty meeting
the requirements of EPA General permits
and uh sometimes that re the the
recommended um uh fixes from EPA are
outside the fiscal capacity of the towns
that are being asked to make those um
those adjustments uh and even for towns
that do and cities that do have a larger
fiscal capacity it's still a substantial
burden and in some cases it's not clear
that the uh that the science being used
to set those permit requirements is
necessarily in line with the current
conditions on the ground and this is
something that uh could probably be
handled uh with more agility by uh the
state Dees than by the EPA uh there are
only three states where these permits
are uh are put done by the EPA rather
than the state on New Hampshire is one
of those Massachusetts is another I'm
forgetting what the third was but in
almost every state it's the state Dees
or equivalent that is figuring out how
to do the permitting for these and that
allows more flexibility
in terms of how those permits are
structured so I think that we should
look into having our Dees uh take on
this job so that they can really respond
to uh what is uh necessary in
um uh to have our communities make make
appropriate adjustments but still but do
that within means another part of
potentially doing that within means is
uh making more uh
more funding available to uh towns and
cities to be able to to do these
programs once they're determined to be
necessary and uh a third a third thing
is that there are some uh uh communities
in for instance in the lake W Winn pasak
Basin that have uh put together uh a
joint Waters um treatment uh facility
that covers a number of different towns
s uh that and they join together and
that can provide more uh efficiency in
terms of uh the dealing with the costs
those are all options that uh need to be
considered it's something we're not
going to not going to figure out before
the deadline for this bill so that's why
I'm saying we should have a study
committee to look at this um
and uh so so that's that's what the
basically what the study committee will
be studying thank you any comments from
the
committee representative kraton and
then yes Madam chair uh I I seconded
this
bill um or this amendment uh because
although the bill I thought was not
something I would vote for um it
definitely highlighted a critical
problem within the state of New
Hampshire and its relationship with the
Environmental Protection Agency and that
and the fact that
uh oftentimes their more heavy-handed
actions can really hurt the folks in
this state um and so I applaud
representative Bixby who put this
together with a deadline of one November
uh so this is a tight turn this isn't a
push down the road this is uh something
where I think we can make a difference
in the state um by working together to
to come up with reasonable Solutions
over thank you representative
Penza so this is more of a procedural
question because I my I have an
amendment as well so I I don't know how
this works right
so well we I support representative
bixby's Amendment my amendment's like
completely slicing the cat the different
way so does your Amendment would it
eliminate this amendment I don't C yet I
think it
would represent
Penza
um if it's a replacement amendment that
would replace the bill then it would
take away everything that we're
discussing
now I I in in speaking with you about
your proposed amendment I believe that
um that discussion for what you're
proposing could be part of the study
committee of what they can be looking at
um because you are your Amendment seeks
to try
to yeah okay um sorry yeah we should be
voting on this and then discussing your
Amendment but
um I I I'm at this point I'm not sure
that your Amendment would I think it
would replace this particular Amendment
as well so okay um any other discussion
about this amendment representative
Brown yes thank you Mr chairman um the
question I have is has da Dees indicated
their willingness or ability or their
thoughts on their ability to do this for
the state thank you uh Dees has not
weighed in on this it's been a pretty
tight turnaround in terms of getting the
amendment I I physically got the
amendment about um five minutes before
this executive session started uh but
one of the reasons that I an important
reason for making this a study committee
rather than just saying do this is
because uh with a study committee we can
bring in Dees and really discuss with
them what it would take for them to do
it I'm I'm I'm sure that they will need
more funding to do it uh and and they
can but they can explain what that
funding would be like uh they can
explain uh how this works in other
states that they that they are cooperate
with and they know how the process works
so I the I expect them to be fully
involved in the process process of this
discussion okay any other discussion
representative
ger thank you madam chair and I I want
to Echo representative kon's uh comments
a bit and say uh that I think that this
was a really nice job on a quick
turnaround of getting us a bill that
hopefully can have some impact for
residents of some of these towns like
you know the the original uh bill was
highly problematic for for a lot of
reasons uh but I think we all saw that
there was a real need there and as you
said with a with a really tight
turnaround whatever you know if in the
end you know Dees says no we really
can't do this uh you know that's
unfortunate but as you said at least
we're moving in a positive direction to
try to do something for folks um so I
also applied representative Bixby for
his hard work and getting us this
amendment thank you there's no other
discussion then I would like the uh
clerk to call a role uh to vote on this
amendment thank you madam chair uh we
are voting on adopting Amendment 202
4478 for Bill hb1 1294 representative
kraton I represent coma yes represent
Moffet I represent Davis represent Bean
yes represent kulan yes represent Brown
yes represent
Penza yes represent smart yes represent
Bixby yes represent sopitas yes
representative dutsi yes representative
Murray yes representative Jama yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes represent NAB
yes represent moris yes bman yes Madam
chair yes 20 amendment is
adopted okay and I believe represent
Penza you have an amendment that you'd
like to
bring like to make a
motion I don't know what to do right
here I'm just gonna be completely honest
so you can you can
you
can yes uh we could uh have a discussion
of the bill in general and then discuss
how that um potential Amendment might or
might not fit in and then uh without
actually moving the amendment
okay okay uh so do we hear a motion for
otpa on um hb1
1294 no well
um I'm not sure if we need to well yeah
you want to have the discussion though
about how the her Amendment
May
okay so would you like to describe this
amendment that you your idea yes so it's
pretty simple so the um the the prime
sponsor of the bill you know came off
you know kind of guns of Blazing about
the um you know how we put that forward
but it was because of an issue that's
been going on in straford County so um
which I've heard from multiple
constituents first starting in Dober and
then of course in Rochester
so this amendment basically just
corrects the problem that um and it's
clear it says in bold towns shall be
prohibited from entering into a contract
that has taxpayer liability including
fees or fines without approving such
contracts through the normal Municipal
budget process so it's as simple as that
um that that corrects the that corrects
a problem that where everybody was
really flipping out because they were
going to possibly be on the hook for a
Rain Tax
so I don't I don't know how this could
be incorporated I'm not really sure sure
I don't know if maybe I could add this
to another bill somewhere in our in our
genre here the stuff that we're doing
but um I think this is important because
it immediately puts a correction into a
a
problem representative Bixby so I I
think that um this that this issue in
terms of um how the um the town
management is not necessarily being
appropriately constrained by the town um
uh elected body uh is really a question
for either the Judiciary Committee or
the um Municipal and County government
committee because uh I I I don't think
we have the expert expertise in our
committee to deal with this I think that
is that um that it is a problem if a
Town Administrator or city manager is uh
entering into a binding contract without
having the Authority for that voted by
the the municipal body uh and and and
there although there are some you know
there are some things that based on the
way that the the town Charter or city
Charter is constructed may or may not
give permissions and that's something
that we just don't know on this
committee and I think what would make
sense is to um make this a bill for next
term and uh consult with people on um
appropriate committees who know these
things and figure out the best way to
write
it additionally I would think um you
might want to talk to the chairs of
those two committees and see if there is
an appropriate bill that they have
pending that you may be able to put this
amendment attach it
to right yeah just one line so okay okay
okay all right any other
comments okay um why don't we proceed
with uh an otpa motion for uh hb1 1294
do I hear one representative NAB Madam
chair I motion a to pass with a as
amended for uh House Bill 1294 with
amendment I said as amended oh okay
thanks Madam chair I second the motion
thank you uh any further discussion
seeing none
I request the clerk to call the role
please thank you madam chair we're
voting on HB 1294
otpa representative kraton I
representative coma yes representative
Moffet hi represent Davis yes represent
Bean yes represent kulan yes represent
Brown yes represent Penza yes represent
smart yes represent Bixby yes represent
sopus yes represent represent Duty yes
represent Murray yes represent J yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
yes represent NAB yes represent Morris
yes represent bman yes Madam chair
yes it is adopted
20 we hear any objection to putting this
on
consent seeing none make it
so okay I'm moving on to um cacr 14 do I
hear a
motion relating relating to the
environment and natural
resources representative Katon um Madam
chair I move inexpedient to legislate on
CAC
R14 and do I hear a second M
representative Howard Madam chair I
second the the motion thank you um
representative kraton do you would you
like to speak to your motion I yes ma'am
the uh as as we heard testimony and
talked that about this bill to me it
struck me that
uh environment is hugely important to
the state of New Hampshire in fact in it
it's embedded into the mission statement
of the Department of Environmental
Services and the things that we listen
to and and uh discuss every day have
relevant importance to the environment
um but I don't think this bill enhances
our ability to care for the environment
any more than if we did without it and
so uh as we looked at it I I thought
that this was uh not having the intended
effect of improving our environment uh
rather it was uh it was getting lost in
in another document and so uh I stand by
the dees mission statement which is to
protect our environment and I just
reread it and it's straight up in the
first sentence and so I I would stand by
what what we're doing and continue to to
do great things I don't think we need a
cacr to do that over thank you
representative vix so
um I am not entirely opposed to the idea
of having um a something in the
Constitution that explicitly says that
uh marks the value of the environment to
the state of New h but I don't think
that this uh particular amendment is the
one that does it so uh I will be voting
I thank you representative
ger thank you very much Madam chair I
I'm going to oppose the itl motion uh
one of the concerns we have is about
kind of how vague the language is but
all fundamental rights are vague if we
this committee if we had right now the
First Amendment or the Second Amendment
of the United States Constitution in
front of us for the very first time we
would say this is vague how do you
define arms what are the limitations how
far do the rights apply at what point
are they infringed the New Hampshire
Constitution says that every child in
the state has the right to an adequate
education we've been litigating that for
a long time does that mean because it's
a vague statement does that mean because
we haven't been able to find a solution
that we don't believe that children in
the state do have a fundamental right to
an adequate education I don't think so
all
fundamental statements of rights are
vague by definition and then what
happens is through government
representative government we litigate
and we legislate in order to determine
how those fundamental rights are
actually applied and realized and
protected in society but the purpose for
putting them in these foundational
documents is to make a statement that
they are exactly that that they are
foundational
rights uh we weren't
any of us born being able to speak and
yet we have a First Amendment that
guarantees our right to the freedom of
speech and certainly none of us were
born with a gun in our hands and yet we
have a second amendment that protects
our constitutional right to bear arms
each and every one of us was born
needing to be able to breathe clean air
and drink clean water and eat produce
that comes from clean land so as far as
I'm concerned there simply is no more
fundamental right than the right to a
clean and healthy environment and I
understand and recognize my colleague
representative kulan who had who said
during our discussion that it's as he
sees it this is kind of a placeholder
for
lawsuits yeah we've spent more than 200
years with lawsuits over the first and
second amendments and other aspects of
the Bill of Rights there's scarcely a
fundamental right outlined in the United
States or the New Hampshire state
constitution that has not been the
subject of further clarification through
legislation or challenges through
litigation uh so as I said uh among the
many rights that we recognized as being
absolutely fundamental I don't believe
that there is one more fundamental than
the right that is uh that this cacr
proposes that we enshrine in the State
Constitution and for that reason I
oppose the uh the itl and and look
forward to uh fighting for it on the
floor thank you madam chair thank you
any other representative sopak kitis I
think that um we do a disservice to um
the after Generations from where we live
now when we don't make a statement
of where we feel on things and I think
that a cacr is that we have um given the
youth an environment that's
teetering and how I explain it to the
youth is that they're the people that
have to go along after the parade and
clean up the elephant poop and they are
going to have huge work ahead of them
and it's going to be sitting right on
our shoulders and they will say what did
you do for us to help us through this
and this cacr is a mission St statement
it's a mission statement that we
recognize that there are
issues I live in nsha just north of
nashwa is marac marac is a cancer
cluster marac has um it's
groundwater is
contaminated it's got this beautiful
plant St gobain that was recruited there
from Vermont because Vermont showed them
the door because they liked our lack of
regulations
more and they have BL we have the
highest bladder cancer in the country
and that cancer belt goes
from marac all the way over to the coast
and
so I just find I'm going to support this
um a toath I'll vote against the itl
because it's a mission
statement representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair I too will oppose the
itl for the reasons that my colleagues
have stated I I think it's an important
message to send I look forward to
working on it and supporting it um and I
hope we get the chance to make that
argument on the floor thank you
representative Howard thank you madam
chair um I agree with my colleagues who
uh who want to send out a mission
statement and have it you know
emboldened in our constitution I however
I believe that the inelegance of the
language limits the efficacy of the of
the amendment so thank
you okay without any other uh comment I
would request the clerk call the rooll
thank you madam chair the motion is itl
on cacr 14 representative kraton I
representative ktoa yes represent
Moffett hi represent Davis yes represent
Bean yes represent kulon yes represent
Brown yes represent Penza yes represent
smart yes represent
Bixby uh yes represent
sopitas no represent Duty no represent
Murray no represent Jam no represent H
Haskins no representative Howard yes
represent n
yes represent Morris no represent
bman no and Madam chair yes on
itl
13-7 the motion of itl
passes thank
you madam chair do we know who was going
to write The Minority
Report um well let's see um I
guess oh representative ger will write
The Minority
Report and representative Katon will
write the minor majority
report okay let me just write that
down thank you all right all right now
we are going to move along
to HB 1630 relative to Extended producer
responsibility and I would like to make
the motion of
itl on this bill um do I hear a second
representative Davis
seconds and I will speak to this um this
bill this uh uh motion um HB 1630 the uh
extended producer responsibility
bill in my my Sitting On Solid Waste
working group and working with
representative eel on that I have
discussions with her about um the epr uh
extended producer
responsibility
and um I agree with her thoughts on this
legislation is that it there are a lot
of components to to this it's a very
complicated Bill the thought is that the
way we should and and this is
legislation uh model legislation that's
come from another
organization uh a National
Organization and the thought is that the
way we should attack uh epr in the state
is through smaller pieces we we have um
bills that are dealing with with Banning
lithium batteries we have uh bills that
are talking about um bottle return and
we have other bills that deal with other
issues having to do with recycling or
how what are we putting in our landfill
so I think we are already addressing epr
in several smaller pieces which makes
sense because there's not a one-size
fits-all um to this to this issue and
that is why I am not in favor of this
particular
Bill any other further comments
represent Bixby yeah so um I was uh I
was sort of hoping to to have this as an
interim study bill as opposed to uh an
itl because I think that uh we really
need to study uh this as a um I I think
that we can't just
uh wait until wait for another uh uh
term to go by before coming up with uh
with some sort of solid legislation that
we can submit next term and this is
really complicated and I think that um
that
uh although um representative parshall
did look at some model legislation he
actually spent a lot of time
uh trying to uh mold his bill uh to
address more things than was in any
piece of model legislation that was
there uh I don't uh unfortunately I
don't think that his bill is is as
written is workable uh and I think part
of the problem was that he was pretty
much doing it on his own this is uh this
is something that really requires more
than one person working on it with many
stakeholders coming in to uh uh to help
us uh put together a bill that will work
I think that uh when we had the um the
representative from the Plastic industry
in last week and I I thank Madam chair
for uh having uh in invited that
presentation uh one of the things that
became clear was that it might make more
sense to rather than to say all
packaging to say let's focus on one
sector and uh so perhaps an epr bill
that uh just PL just focuses on the
Plastics sector and we can get
representatives from the Plastics
industry we can get representatives from
the uh uh conservation law Foundation we
can get uh representatives from uh Dees
from there a whole range of stakeholders
to help us figure out how to put
together a more targeted epr bill but we
need to be working on it and uh there
are two avenues for working on that uh
one is uh that we could do this as an
interim study the other is that we could
in fact do an ad hoc uh series of
subcommittee meetings uh in order to
meet that same goal and that in fact in
fact may give us more flexibility than a
than a um than a interm study so um as
long as we really commit to doing those
ad hoc sessions I'd be willing to
support the itl but I think that we
absolutely need to study this and have a
piece of legislation prepared for next
term yeah representative Bixby I would
be totally amable
to an itl on this bill and then uh
having our subcommittees work on pieces
of uh epr legislation I think that would
be prudent as an ad hoc as opposed to an
interim study representative Murray
thank you madam chair I although my
preference might be more for the interim
study I will um support the commitment
to an ad hoc committee because I do
agree um we've talked for years now
about extended producer responsibility
and how that fits into the framework uh
and we heard folks uh who did give the
presentation last time that uh they
recognized that that's an integral part
of how recycling functions not only uh
in the United States but elsewhere
across the globe and uh to not have that
considered um and worked on while um I
agree there are problems with this
current bill um we absolutely have to
look at epr agree anyone else
representative kraton
yes ma'am I I agree completely that
reducing the amount of plastics and
waste at this at the at the Inception
point is important I'd be willing to
assist with the subcommittee effort uh
one of the things about this bill that
that jumped out of me was that it the
cost of eight
Personnel uh is pushing a million bucks
which is not currently in the budget and
and I think that if we're going to pass
a bill that as other colleagues have
stated is not exactly what we want and
we're going to spend a million bucks on
it I think that is is uh not responsible
um but I do believe that working
together we can figure out some way to
get the pieces and parts of this that
are important into the next session
thank you representative ger thank you
madam chair uh I support interim study
as I did when we discussed this before a
very distant second would be the ad hoc
commit and I certainly would be uh very
happy to to help out with the work of
that committee uh and I will certainly
oppose itl thank you thank you
representative smart you had your hand
up no oh no I didn't oh representative
Duty uh yes thank you madam chair uh
first of all with all due respect I
think we have a number of bills that
come before our committee that are based
on model legislation and I think today
we will probably be voting on at least
two other bills that were based on model
legislation so I would certainly
you know um not want to not consider a
bill because of that um secondly I agree
with my um colleagues um that this is an
extremely important issue I would say
you know I understand the need to
partializing uh but on the other hand I
also think because we've seen so many
epr bills come through and a lot of them
basically have the same administrative
structure uh which means a producer
responsibility organization that
collects fees from um producers people
who produce the trash that
municipalities have to pay for I think
basically we should be thinking in a you
know more uh broad scope in terms of
possibly having a department or a
division under one of our departments
that basically
handles uh producer responsibility
organizations and under that we then
partializing a uh interim study
committee we can bring all the people
forward for it so I would be voting
against itl thank you anyone
else oh sure go ahead representative ger
you had something to add well yeah just
because with representative Duty
referring to the fact that this is model
legislation it reminded me of something
that I wanted to say when we had the
hearing and that is uh it's not
necessarily bad when we have model
legislation we tend to use that as if
it's a negative term but in this
particular case one of the things that
we've talked a lot about is if something
like this is going to be successful it's
going to have to be part of a regional
plan right and it's ultimately going to
have to be part of a a national plan and
the only way to move in that direction
actually is for several states to be
working from the same basic model
legislation so we have similar
definitions similar understandings of
the processes so I just did want to
thank representative Duty for making
that comment because it reminded me that
I had wanted to to say that during the
hearing thank you okay thank you um with
that I would like the clerk to call the
role for itl motion thank you madam
chair motion is itl on HP 1630
representative kraton hi represent ktoa
yes represent Moffet hi represent Davis
yes represent Bean yes represent kulon
yes represent Brown yes represent Penza
yes represent smart yes represent Bixby
yes represent sopus no represent dutsi
no represent Murray yes represent jamana
no represent H Haskins nay represent
Howard no represent NAB no represent
Morris no represent Bushman no madame
chair
yes 128 the motion of itl is
adopted may ask who will write The
Minority
Report who who
that okay Dy
okay okay um moving along to HB
1184 relative to making an appropriation
to The Organic certification program do
I hear a motion representative kulan
thank you madam chair I'd like to move
itl on hb1
184 do I hear a second um I I second
that thank you would you like to um
speak to your motion representative
kolan I I'd love to um first thing I
want to say is that I know everyone on
this committee supports organic farming
and we all think and believe that they
provide real value and enrich the soil
and the air and all the elements um
however when we also talk about organic
farming uh we talk about sustainability
a lot and we've been told by the
commissioner that this plan um this
program is unsustainable and will never
be uh financially sustainable we also
see an organic um migration away from
State uh certifiers and we also know
that uh there's multiple other options
for Organic certification so no one is
being left out in the cold so to speak
so while some of us on
um some of us in our caucus you know we
think you know we maybe we should just
let this go but the thing is is that um
if we stick to our principles we know
that subsidies they compound and they uh
snowball over time so we don't think
that the New Hampshire taxpayers should
be left on the hook for this program so
for that reason um
I move itl today represent Bixby so um I
would oppose the itl and uh one of the
things that uh is important to remember
in this process is that back in the
1990s it was the our Department of
Agriculture approached the organic
community and said we can do this for
you and to
uh back out of that suddenly is a real
problem now it is possible that the
long-term resolution for this is to move
it more towards a private uh
organization doing the
certification but we don't it would be a
real disservice to our organic certified
organic community in the state of New
Hampshire to suddenly pull out pull all
the funding away from this
and uh leave them without an option in
the short term uh there are discussions
that are happening with NOA New
Hampshire and uh other certifying bodies
in the area that could could create a
satellite program where there would be
it would be possible to have New
Hampshire organic crops and uh and
animal products and uh um and uh value
added products labeled as produced in
New Hampshire with a New Hampshire uh
with with a New
Hampshire uh Organic
certification uh label that is also
certified by a out of another
organization uh like one of one of the
existing or um uh accredited uh aca's um
accredited certifying uh
agencies uh but it's going to take it's
going to take some time to get that
program together and we need to support
our uh our farmers in the interim so uh
this is uh this is not going to be
something we're going to be funding
forever but it's something that we need
to fund in the short term in order to
give our organic farmers uh time to uh
develop a better option and uh it is
part of allowing our Department of
Agriculture to uh maintain that
commitment that they made a number of
years ago that they would help our
organic community so I I see that bring
taking the funding suddenly is a uh is a
real uh disservice it is a um turning
back on a uh commitment that was made by
the department and I am completely
completely against it however uh one
thing that
um that the uh representative from the
Farm Bureau brought up uh uh was the
possibility of a sunset uh if we
overturn the itl then I'd be willing I I
have an amendment that would place a
sunset on on on the positions and uh I'd
be happy to bring that forward if given
the opportunity represent Murray thank
you madam chair and if I May while we're
having this discussion for the record
acknowledge the letter that we received
from the Farm Bureau this morning um
regarding their position on Organic
certification uh by damp and I just
wanted to make sure that that was clear
to folks I think we all receive the
letter yeah I just just summarize sure
so um for those um it the Farm Bureau
starts uh addressing it to the chair and
the members of the committee and in the
second paragraph says that we want to
make clear that the F Bureau policy
support stamp providing USDA organic
certification Services provided the
program is self-funded it f further goes
on uh and and talks about uh
organizations outside of the State of
New Hampshire but then also uh notes
that for reasons that we have outlined
within this document we believe the
program is important enough to give it a
real shot to succeed since stamp uh made
stakeholders aware in the summer of 2021
of the issues it was facing with the
program we do not believe it has been
given that
opportunity thank you I'd like to add
though that
um they don't support having a program
you just read that they don't support
having the program if it's not self
self-funded and what we're hearing from
the commissioner is that it won't ever
be
self-funded um especially based on the
amount of personnel they're going to
need uh in their Department to do that
that's where my problem is with this
belt is that
um right
now the cost well the cost for an
organic farmer to get certified through
New
Hampshire uh Department of Agriculture
is pretty
inexpensive and if only 66 Farms right
now are availing themselves of this I
can imagine that it would be even less
with the fees going up up which it would
have to uh even with the subsidies so
I'm not I'm just not convinced that this
is um this is going to be a good program
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair and I think when we're talking
about uh this program being uh
self-funding we've already seen even
though New Hampshire certific Organic
certification is less expensive than the
other certifying agencies half of the or
certified organic farms have already
left the state
program representative
Howard um the letter also goes on
besides saying that having a sunset
um uh on the on the on the bill they um
he also suggests that that they use that
time to become self-sufficient um I
think that uh I think that we need to
give it a shot we need to give them a
chance to to come around and I think
part of the reason that that those other
the other half of is because the the
state no longer does um meet or anything
other than crops so I think the people I
I would guess that the people who have
dropped out probably were didn't you
know needed greater coverage than the
state provides representative
kraton thank you ma'am I'm just looking
at my notes and and
essentially uh I agree with uh
representative kulon that organic
farming is critical to the the viability
of Agriculture on the state but the the
numbers are what what hit me it's a
$220,000 bill that supports roughly 66
farms and so if it's to be self-
sustaining then you're talking about at
least $45,000 per Farm to to have this
process unless you get money from
somewhere else but that that's not in
the bill and so if we're if we're going
to the farmers and we're saying hey we
got this great program for you it's
going to cost you 4,000 bucks good luck
to you I'm not sure we're doing them any
favors and so there may be a better way
to do this but if the if they're going
in pres premises it's
self-funding then I think that this is
not the bill to get that done over thank
you representative Duty yes thank you
madam chair uh I think argument can be
made um that uh the organic farmers
received a disservice uh through the uh
through the management of this program
because uh the fees have never been um
raised so therefore we're in a situation
now where they're unrealistically low uh
in comparison and and I think the
department should take some
responsibility for that the other thing
I have an issue with uh is the term
subsidy uh I would suspect that there's
a lot of programs in uh damp that are
subsidized I mean the one that I can
think of is the invasive species program
uh I'm not sure that that's funded by
any industry um so you could call that a
subsidy also but I mean it's part of
their work the third problem that I have
is that commissioner Jasper came to this
session the legislature has a
responsibility to budget for each
department okay we expect that budgeted
money to be used in service of the
environment and Agriculture and we were
told by commissioner Jasper that he
returns money every year to the general
fund so 20
$220,000 which is probably maximum
because you know the fee should be
raised we all understand that I don't
think that's unreasonable and I
certainly don't I don't think it's
unreasonable to pass an amendment that
gives gives us three years to look at
this and see if it can be
feasible
okay representative
moris thank you madam chair um I'm going
to vote against the itl um and hope that
we can support um representative
bigsby's Amendment um so that we can
have some extra time to look at this and
see how we can make it uh viable moving
forward and I would just like to point
out that um even though we're only
talking about 66 Farms we're also
talking about 66 communities and the
impact that um these Farms have on the
economy and you know the the resources
that they provide to those to those
people so for me when I'm thinking about
our job in the government and
$220,000
um I I feel that it's a good investment
but I also think that you know it's
worth exploring additional ways that
they can become at least more self-
sustainable over the next few years
thank you thank you I appreciate your
comments
um I I I will will get to you I I do
recall uh that commissioner Jasper did
say that he didn't believe that if this
bill was not passed that it would harm
New Hampshire Farm uh organic farmers so
I just want to take that into mind too
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um and thank you for allowing me
to speak again I I I would also like to
say that I think that um investing in
organic farming gives consumers also
another choice and I think that the
state of New Hampshire
um deserves that opportunity to have
both of those options available in the
farming Community for all of the reasons
we've talked about supporting um
communities supporting the farmers um
and I also am eager to see
representative bixby's Amendment come
forward so I will be voting against the
itl okay so why don't I instruct the
clerk to call the role on itl motion uh
for HB
1184 thank you madam chair the motion is
itl representative kraton I
representative kto yes represent Moffett
I represent Davis yes represent Bean yes
represent kulan yes represent Brown yes
represent Penza yes represent smart yes
represent Bixby no represent sopus no
represent Duty no representative Murray
no represent Jama no represent H Haskins
nay represent Howard no represent NAB no
represent Morse no represent mhan no
Madam chair yes it's
101 no
recommendation that motion fails do I
hear another
motion yes I um represent Bixby I um I
moved to uh uh OTP with uh um or I move
Amendment
uh uh 202
24-4 77h to uh HB
1184 and I'd like to speak to my motion
go I hear a second we need a second
second would you like to speak to your
motion representative Bixby yes please
uh so thank you madam chair so uh what
the amendment does is it uh adds a
contingency to the bill so
that uh if it if at the year at the end
of the year uh ending in uh end of the
fiscal year uh ending June 30th
2027 uh the commission determines that
uh insufficient revenues uh are have
been generated by the fees for the pro
for the program uh then uh the two
positions that the bill creates will be
terminated so uh what that does is that
um the the way that this works in terms
of budgeting the fir in the um in the
bill there is
$222,000 for two positions plus uh a car
and computers for uh that for those
people to do the work uh
and that that fun fing will be for
fiscal year
2025 and the uh the next year is a
budget year so uh so 26 and 27 would be
under the budget that we approved for
next term the commissioner would have to
uh put in his budget request the
salaries for those two positions uh that
would be less than the
$220,000 because uh it doesn't include
the equipment and that equipment will be
still good for for for the following
years uh so uh we're probably looking at
somewhere in the 150 to $180,000 range
uh per year in the next budget that the
and the commissioner will ha will have
to request though that for his budget uh
unless there is something that comes up
that says that uh well actually I'm get
I'll get to that un last on next after
after I talk about how the amendment
works so uh if at the end of 2020 uh if
in June of
2027 insufficient funds have come in
through fees to pay for those two
positions then these the positions will
automatically terminate and they'll the
the commissioner will not be required at
any point in the future to request re
EST funding for those
positions now if something comes up uh
at the end of fiscal year
2025 and the commissioner determines
that it really is impossible to make
this program continue he can put in his
budget request no money for the
positions and language for hb2 saying
that those positions would be would be
terminated so the what uh so what this
amendment does does is it creates a hard
stop that the commissioner does not have
any control over if the money doesn't
come in through fees uh to to completely
fund those two
positions uh but it does not that does
not prevent the commissioner from
determining before then that maybe this
really isn't working uh so uh what we're
really committing to is just the
$220,000 for the coming year uh the
coming fiscal year and that is well
invested in terms of giving the organic
Community time to put together a um a
program that uh will better uh uh better
function for New Hampshire's organic
farmers representative
Penza I would like to understand the
money so I know you just explained that
but I just I want it as simple as
possible so this 2024 is when it's going
to at the end of 2024 is when um it's
the program would be in a sense
dissolved so we're looking at
25 and 26 and then this is 27 so you're
saying that it would only be 220 it
wouldn't
be uh well actually if it's half of a
year so it wouldn't be um 440 then plus
another
110,000 for a half a year so
500 okay 50,000 is what I'm looking at
for a number may may I clarify sure okay
so um the the fiscal the fiscal years
are go from June from the end of June to
the end of June uh so uh fiscal year uh
25 starts on
um uh I it's get because it goes July 1
July starts July
1st of 2024 so and then ends uh July
June 30th of
2025 and uh so the money that the the
$220,000 that is appropriated in the
bill will cover uh July 24 through June
and the um we need to have and then in
order to have any money further it needs
to be part of the Department's budget
request so uh when the uh so uh if the
if the commissioner determines that the
program should continue then he will put
in a request for one and a half
positions and that's ballpark 150
160,000 I depend I don't remember the
exact numbers from the fiscal node in
terms of what the positions were and
what the material was uh but uh that
would be uh per year so that would be uh
if he puts that budget request in it
would be um about 300 a little bit over
300,000 for the following fiscal year if
that gets passed in the budget uh
and uh so uh and that is the maximum
that we would possibly be out uh and
that's going to be offset by fees the
department is going to be raising fees
uh for the uh for next year not for this
com not for the current growing season
but for the next growing season so uh
there'll be a certain amount of onset
from fees that would go against whatever
is budgeted for uh the next FIS fiscal
year okay um in a minute um so thank you
for that representative Bixby but uh the
way I'm hearing this is that there seems
to be a lot of ifs and buts that come
along with this um Amendment and we have
no assurances of whether this is going
to work or
not with the prospect of fees absolutely
going to have to go up I'm expecting
that there's going to be even less
participation than the 66 organic
farmers that we currently have so that
is why I'm thinking that um I I I think
um I'd vote against an otpa
representative
Penza that's exactly what I was just
going to say so in kind of going based
upon what representative Duty said right
so we go from a very minimal fees that
these people are expecting and then they
get hit all in one time so it could be
increased by you know a few thousand
dollars so then we have you know the
program bleeds these
Farmers I don't know I just I don't
think that this I just don't think that
it's well thought out and this is
probably one of the hardest bills
because I'm so supportive of this
community I spend all of the extra money
to buy all those kinds of produce
locally as well and so I just think that
there's a better way and I I just don't
believe that this is it representative
Howard I think it could go just the
opposite direction as well if if we were
to um create If This Were to spin-off of
a private certification agency that is
that is housed in New Hampshire it could
draw New Hampshire Farms back in and
create an economy of scale because if
you're growing in in New Hampshire isn't
it better to be certified in New
Hampshire representative
comto thank you Madame
chair
um I agree this is tough right we wanton
our organic certified Farms but we do
know that we have half of our certified
crop farms already being certified
elsewhere we also heard the commissioner
state that currently he only has one I
believe it was one organic
certifier right now if that person
leaves the program
fails and I also believe that he said to
train a person it will take up to
months so if we hired someone and got
them up to Snuff it's a year and a half
out and I could be wrong but that's what
I thought he said representative Murray
thank you madam chair I also want to
make sure that we're not losing sight of
the fact that we do have a sort of
Cooperative agreement um
through um the USDA Farm Service Agency
around Organic certification cost
sharing
reimbursements um so there is some of
that that will help offset the costs to
organic farmers as well um that they can
apply for and I I just didn't want that
to be um represent Bixby yeah I just
want to clarify um what what the uh what
the status of Organic certification um
Personnel in the department is right now
right now we have two people who are
fully certified and uh and and working
and we have another person who is uh
approaching the end of her training and
will very soon be certified and what the
what the commissioner wanted in terms of
uh having certified um
Personnel available and uh and sort
of uh existing as positions and statute
was to in order to make sure that he
would have a buffer in case someone left
he'd always have someone available to uh
to fill in those shoes so uh it's it so
so right now there is not a an impending
crisis of someone leaving unless three
people leave all at once representative
com uh thank you madam chair and this is
just a question for represent Bixby I
don't know if you know that so currently
we have three
people that will go out to 66 farms uh
to certify them organically is that what
you're
saying um what I'm saying is that we
have three people who are qualified and
uh are recognized by the USDA as
certifiers and they do not spend most of
their their time doing that uh so I
think there is one of them that does
that is spending most of her time doing
that the other two do it on a uh do it
part-time as needed to fill in the gaps
when that one person uh it
has when that one that one workload is
too much so I think in terms of the
actual amount of work that is uh
required for uh the certification uh I
think that is essentially one and a half
full-time uh people's worth of work and
most of the work is not going out to the
farm and inspecting most of the work is
uh looking at the paperwork filed by
those Farms making sure that they uh
that they're consistent with the program
requirements and uh if there are
inconsistencies letting those Farmers
know that they need to address those Inc
consistencies uh I I think if we want to
have more detail about how that time is
spent uh we could probably ask uh
director Wyman but I'm not sure that's a
good use of our time I think we know
where this is going and we probably want
to move on towards a vote Yes I I would
agree I like to call the vote okay thank
you
um representative kto please call the
role so the motion is to adopt uh
Amendment 202
40477 for Bill HB 1184 representative
kraton mayay Representative ktoa no
representative Moffet no representative
Davis no represent Bean no represent
kulon nay represent Brown no represent
Penza no represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent
sopus yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent ger yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB yes representative moris yes
representative ban
yes madame chair no Amendment fails
1010 Madam chair I would like to move
represent speak I'd like to move ought
to
pass ought to pass
Amendment uh do I hear a second or is
this ought to pass the bill just OTP
Amendment Amendment failed so I'm just
I'm moving moving OTP okay so he's
moving OTP
represent hold on just a moment
please
okay uh representative Bixby uh you made
a motion a to pass do I hear a
second representative Murray seconds uh
and representative Bixby uh if you'd
like briefly to uh speak to your motion
I suspect we know where this is going to
go so let's just do it okay uh all right
so I'd like the clerk to call the rooll
on this motion is OTP on HB 1184
representative kraton nay representative
coma no representative Moffett no
representative Davis no representative
Bean no Representative kulan no
represent Brown no represent Penza no
represent smart no
representative Bixby yes representative
sopitas yes representative Duty yes
representative Murr yes represent Jama
yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard represent NAB yes representative
moris yes represent ban yes madame
chair uh OTP
no 10 10 you can join us
uh no
recommendation okay um so I guess um we
have two we have to write two committee
reports so I'll write one and you write
the other okay got it all right moving
along thank you everybody um moving
along to hb1 1618 mandating a
Cooperative agreement with USDA for
Organic
certification
um yes sir uh may ask would it be
possible for the committee to have a a
very short break to step away to do for
a few minutes because we still have a
few more bills to go through and I think
some folks could uh use a short break um
okay U I would recess for three minutes
if you need a time
okay okay
I'm
uh yeah she is she's still doing
that minutes
yeah stretch get minutes
left
okay I'd like our members to please take
their
seats
okay represent sofikitis
there you go be my
head
okay um we're going to continue with our
exec for uh excuse me HB 1618 mandating
a Cooperative agreement with USDA for
Organic certification do I hear an a
motion Madam chair uh representative
ktoa thank you I make a motion to itl do
I hear a
second chair yes Madam chair I second
the motion representative NAB
seconds um would you like to speak to
your motion representative ktoa thank
you madam chair um although this uh bill
was well-intentioned um it would
mandate
um that the Department of Agriculture
enter into a cooperate agreement with uh
the uni
USDA and that they
shall have a certification program for
all
um farming whether it be Dairy meat crop
the cost of the taxpayers is over a
million dollars I believe per year for
this
[Music]
um and it currently would be
unsustainable especially with uh the
number of personnel that we would need
to
hire thank you any further discussion
representative Bixby yeah so
so um just sort of following on that uh
this would as as submitted the bill
would re would require uh that all the
department uh cover all four of the USDA
organic Scopes which is well beyond the
Department's current means and even if
we gave them the money they wouldn't
have the Personnel to do it uh even if
the bill were amended to Simply require
them to do the crop part if the number
of people being certified dropped to a
very low number the department would not
have the option of pulling out they
would still have to do it so that's just
not really tenable so I'm going to be
voting it thank
you any further discussion not i' have
the uh clerk call the role
please Madam chair the motion is itl on
hb1 1618 representative kraton I
representative ktoa yes representative
Ma
hi represent Davis yes represent Bean
yes represent kulon yes represent Brown
yes represent Penza yes represent smart
represent Bixby yes represent sopus yes
represent Duty represent Murray yes
represent Jam yes represent H Haskins I
represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent Morris yes represent ban yes
Madam chair yes
20 without objection may we put this on
consent thank
you okay move along to HB
1182 um hold on one second adding
certain equin practices to definition of
animal cruelty and I would like to move
itl do I hear a
second representative smart
seconds
right can't hear me no now we can hear
you now you can hear me okay and I would
like to speak to my motion on um HB
1182 now um this
bill
absolutely outlines some pretty
heinous uh
actions having to do with animal cruelty
for
horses no one disputes
that but in my discussions with some of
um legal people in uh the
house the sentiment was that these
crimes are so heinous that they already
fall under um our statute having to do
with um animal
cruelty and
the animal cruelty statute is Broad
enough that we don't need
to uh specifically
state every single kind of Cruelty that
can be imagine for these
animals yes we do have specific
statutes um in the animal cruelty stat
in the animal cruelty statutes having to
do with animals in a motor vehicle
docking the tail of a horse as being
cruel practices but those practices were
identified simply because they may not
necessarily be um viewed as cruel
leaving a dog in a
car
or making a horse's tail
shorter so the fact that these crimes
are so blatantly
cruel is already covered under Section
644 colon 8 and um so I had I believe
that um making this kind of Bill law
only opens the door to adding a plethora
of specific kinds of Cruelty to statute
where we don't need it and that um
um we would do so at the probably um
there would be some things that we would
leave out that people would then you
know not consider as being cruel so for
all those I I just believe it's an
unnecessary bill um we already have
these kinds of um out the the things
that are outlined in this bill as being
federally um uh out banned and outlawed
and as well as the equin Federation also
believes that these um kinds of
activities are cruel so uh I I believe
it's an unnecessary Bill and that's why
I am moving to Ita representative Murray
thank you madam chair I also wanted to
to make sure in the absence of any law
enforcement that was able to come before
the committee um I agree these are
heinous reprehensible practices that
should not be done to any animal let
alone a horse um but I would also like
to say it kept me up thinking about the
fact that um the first offense would be
a misdemeanor when in fact I don't know
there may be a first offense that would
be a felony and so the language of the
bill says that any First Defense would
be considered um a misdemeanor and I I
feel that that might actually take away
some power um during an investigative
process from law enforcement but I
didn't hear from anyone to be able to
say anything about that thank you
representative
ger thank you madam chair uh I I was
hoping that in the course of discussing
this bill we would have somebody from
the Attorney General's office or
somebody else who could actually give us
some some expert uh guidance in terms of
what helps with prosecution what hinders
prosecution because my mind could be
swayed I'm going to oppose the itl
depending on what I might have heard
from the attorney general or some other
prosecutor I might have been able to to
go along with uh support the itl
representative ger I don't mean to
interrupt you I did get in touch with
the AG's office they didn't want to
discuss the bill uh because they don't
give out that kind of advice okay I
appreciate that I still it in in my mind
I I don't have any reason to believe one
way or the other that this is going to
be a problem for prosecution so for me
uh that's an issue but I thank you for
that clarification and I I do also want
to say that in terms of law enforcement
issues law enforcement um probably
aren't right now really looking for
these things these specific things and I
think that the the virtue of legislation
like this is it actually does direct law
enforcement towards specific acts of
animal cruelty so I'll be opposing the
itl thank you representative Bixby yeah
so I was kind of on the fence until I
had a chance to talk with representative
Murray last night about it and uh for
those who of you who don't know uh
representative Murray has spent a lot of
time in the eoin world uh so uh she know
she knows more than she just mentioned
uh one of the things that she mentioned
in our conversation was that uh the um
the horse the organizations that run
horse shows are generally fairly good
about policing their members not
Flawless everyone you know not everyone
is going to get every single instance of
of uh of failure to meet the regular
their their requirements but these these
practices are uh generally B banned by
by all of the horse
organizations uh so uh that's one aspect
of it the other aspect that really got
me thinking that this bill is not only
not necessary but is could be
counterproductive is the issue of the
fact that the first offense is
inevitably going to be a misdemeanor
when uh under this bill but our C our
cruelty statutes say that if someone is
purposively harming an
animal that is a felony and I don't want
someone who's doing these things to be
get to get off with a Misti meter when
they really should be charged with a
felony thank
you represent sofikitis
I've also heard from faers and they felt
that the language was too vague and
general um so they were afraid that they
would would be caught up in the in the
um in the bill that it their their trade
would be considered cruel thank
you okay I I will direct the um clerk to
call the rule on itl motion thank you
madam chair itl HB 1182 representative
kraton I representative coma yes
representative Moffet I representative
Davis yes represent Bean yes represent
kulan yes represent Brown yes represent
Penza yes represent smart yes representa
Bixby yes represent
sopus yes representative Duty yes
representa Murray yes represent Jama no
represent H Haskins nay represent Howard
yes represent NAB no represent moris yes
represent bman yes yes Madam chair yes
173 the iil motion
passes would we consider putting this on
consent no okay does someone want to do
a Minority Report who will do the
Minority Report representative
NAB she voted oh
no
okay and I will do the majority
report okay the next uh Bill we have on
our table here is HB
1680 which is relative to prohibiting
the sale of dogs and cats by retail Pet
Shops do I hear a
motion representative Penza yes I'd like
to make a motion for inexpedient to
legislate thank you do I hear a second I
second thank you representative kraton
representative penzo would you like to
speak to your motion
yes so we need to support legislation
that like accurately defines problems so
and whenever this body is like proposing
to implement regulating legislation we
need to ensure that it actually solves a
problem so this bill simply does not do
that if there is a sourcing problem in
New Hampshire that is where the focus of
legislation should go for example there
is more regulation taking place in the
private sector than there is in the
nonprofit sector right now health health
certificates should be required for all
entities in the state where people are
paying for a dog or cat if any of the
New Hampshire pet stores are being
deceptive in their business practices or
selling sick animals there is already a
pathway the public should be be
utilizing to report to the Department of
Justice the C uh which is the consumer
protection in antitrust Bureau that is
the reason why I can't support this Bill
thank
you all right um for me I'd just like to
say um I also believe that if we want to
have a conversation about where our uh
pet stores are sourcing their animals
from we can have that conversation but
to Simply say we're going to ban pet
stores I believe that that is an an
anti-business type of sentiment and I
can't support that representative cron
uh thank you madam
chair going over my notes and the
testimony I I agree with everything's
been said before this but
uh I do not believe from testimony that
this will eliminate puppy
mills I don't believe that it will
achieve the effects that they authors
wanted it to achieve and I think the
puppy mills uh could sell through other
other
means uh and that this harms the
businesses without solving the problem
that the that the Crafters uh intended
thank you okay represent
dsy uh yes I will be voting against the
itl uh I think this bill is a good first
step uh I don't think we have any Silver
Bullet as far as um puppy mills are
concerned um but again um there uh these
bills that have been passed in other
states it's been shown that uh the puppy
mill business has been decreased in
those States I think we've kicked the
can down the road uh long enough on this
we recognize that we need you know a
vast array of regulations to try to cut
this uh problem uh down uh I don't know
about my colleagues but I received you
know I don't know 200 400 I stopped
counting uh half in support half in
opposed but when I opened up the bills
for opposed they came from Washington
Oregon Missouri is always the place Iowa
um those were the bills in support okay
so I have to question um you know what
what stake do they have in US passing a
bill like this so I would encourage my
colleagues to to re-evaluate their stand
on this and consider this a first
step represent ger thank you very much
Madam chair uh I agree that this isn't
going to to solve the entire problem but
we can't legislate for the entire
country we legislate for the State of
New Hampshire and so for that reason I
will uh oppose the itl representative
Murray thank you madam chair for the
record I just want to state that back in
March of 22 2022 uh to my district
article 33 was placed on the ballot and
I did receive a letter in writing from
the town of Amhurst stating the voter's
intent for there to be it was roughly
2,000 2200 voters in favor of uh
stopping puppy mill pipelines to 600 and
some odd members 670 maybe in opposition
um and I did want to say that I am
because I believe that this bill
currently as it stands right now is not
dealing with the underlying issue of the
sourcing of animals and I think that we
had a very lengthy discussion about
sourcing animals and um that that
impacted a wide variety of of entities
that deal with pets um so I just wanted
that um acknowledged for the record okay
thank you with that I'd like to oh
represent Bixby yes
so um my uh my feeling on this bill is
that uh it is not it is not going to be
effective in doing what it wants to do
which is have an impact on puppy mills
the volume of dogs that are sold in New
Hampshire is a small fraction of what
one BR one puppy mill breeder would be
producing a small fraction and uh that
is and there are and there are lotss of
these um problematic breeders out there
we don't we do not have enough retail
establishments in New Hampshire for this
to have an actual impact and given that
the existing ones are uh are um given a
grandfather clause in this bill makes
that uh that market impact even smaller
I think what we need to do is something
like what the commissioner was
suggesting in terms of looking more
broadly at the issue of problematic pet
sourcing and looking at all the channels
that pets come into the state through
and figuring out what sort of more
comprehensive legislation we can come up
with in order to address that issue but
I don't think that this bill is
that thank you representative Bixby I
couldn't agree
more with that I'd like to uh have the
clerk call the role on itl motion for
hb680 thank you madam chair uh motion is
itl hb680 represent of kraton I
represent of coma yes representative
Moffet I represent Davis yes represent
Bean yes represent kulan yes represent
Brown yes represent Penza yes represent
smart yes represent Bixby yes represent
siketus yes represent Duty no represent
Murray
Harry I heard
her
yes represent Jam no representative H
Haskins no represent Howard yes
represent NAB no represent moris no
represent bman no madame chair
yes uh 146 motion of itl is is adopted
okay are we having a Minority
Report
Dy and representative Penza will write
the majority
report okay uh moving along to HB
1572 which is prohibiting using mRNA
technology in food and requireing iring
the labeling of lab grown meat and food
containing insects repres uh do I hear a
motion representative ger thank you
madam chair I move itl on hb1 1572 do I
hear a second I'll second representative
Davis
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion representative gerana I would
thank you very much Madam chair uh I I
think that uh there was broad agreement
that this bill tries to do too much
there are kind of several different
things that aren't uh terribly well
related that are connected in in this
bill uh aspects of it I I think that we
agreed uh are worthy of further pursuit
or further consideration particularly
with regard to people uh getting
accuracy in in labeling but we also
agreed that uh there's very very little
that we can do in the state of New
Hampshire regarding labeling uh and that
initiatives in that respect would have
to come from from the federal government
uh there was also some very unworkable
Provisions in the bill reflecting what I
think was a lack of understanding about
mRNA technology uh that as I said make
provision those specific PR provisions
of the bill on workable and I think we
were all a little bit at a loss to
understand uh the provision regarding uh
ground up insects so uh for all of those
reasons uh I urge my committee members
to committee colleagues to vote itl
thank you representative gerana and I
just want to point out that I have
drafted a letter um which a copy has
been made to all of you with the help of
um our committee researcher Kristen
Grant um I this letter basically is
asking our federal
delegation to uh
pursue um truth and
labeling um legislation at the federal
level I'd like you all we don't want to
I don't want to discuss this letter now
but I would like in lie of you know of
um the motion on this bill I would like
you all to take a look at this um
proposed letter if you have amendments
or changes that you'd like to make to it
or we can as a committee uh maybe next
week uh talk about briefly talk about uh
how we want to word it or reword it or
whatever uh we can certainly do that but
I I I would like to have a letter from
the committee sent to our federal
delegation with regard to Federal
labeling and truth and
labeling any other comments on uh the
motion to
itl represent Bixby yeah so um I am
fully in support of the motion to itl I
just wanted to and I appreciate uh uh
your um Madame chair's uh H putting this
letter together I I I think that it
needs a little bit of editing work but I
think that's something we can do I'm not
sure that we wanted do editing in a 20
person committee I think maybe uh the
chair and I and a couple other people
can look at it and discuss and then
bring back a revised version
super all right
um any other discussion seeing none uh
would like the clerk to call the role on
the it on motion for hb1
1572 thank you madam chair motion is itl
representative kraton I representative
com yes represent Moffet hi represent
Davis yes represent Bean yes represent
kulon yes represent Brown yes represent
Penza yes represent smart yes represent
Bixby yes represent
sopitas represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes represent
H Haskins I represent Howard yes
represent NAB yes represent moris yes
represent Bushman yes madame chair yes
20 the itail motion passes okay would
would we uh be objecting uh putting this
on consent no go ahead let's do
it all right moving along to HB
1565 which is relative to the sale of
Homestead food to Consumers and local
food production do I hear a motion
representative kulan yes mam chair I'd
like to move otpa on HB
1565 so you have to adopt the amendment
an amendment
here yes so read the amendment number uh
the amendment number is
H and I believe everybody has a copy of
that do I hear a second on that itl I
I'm sorry on that um um Amendment motion
representative
Bixby thank you would you like to speak
speak to your motion representative I
love to Madam chair yes um so listening
back to the uh work session uh there
were some legitimate points brought up
by uh DHHS regarding the bill and they
had concerns about um some forms of
canned foods that I thought were very
legitimate concerns so uh yeah in the
you know Spirit of compromise I think
this is a good Fair Amendment and uh I
support the passage of it thank you um
yes I just wanted to point out that I
did have a conversation with um Abigail
Rogers and Colleen Smith from the HHS
food safety which I appreciate their
time and efforts in speaking with me
which uh was the result the result of
which was this amendment which basically
removes processed ACI
acidified uh foods from the potentially
hazardous food
definition and I think that uh that
would be wonderful for our uh local food
producers to be able now to do gold
vegetables and um relishes and salses uh
as other states do that representative
Bixby yeah um I am fully in support of
this amendment I um appreciate the work
of Madam chair with our um
uh good people from food Protective
Services uh I'm I uh I I've done a fair
amount of canning uh over the course of
the years um mostly uh higher acid uh so
tomatoes and pickles and relishes um and
I've also canned other things that
require pressure canning I would be
perfectly
comfortable uh if I were wanted to sell
things selling my high acid can things I
would be hesitant to sell anything that
required the pressure canning because uh
the amount of time the the time
constraints of doing that in a home
kitchen are uh and doing it right are
really high uh so you know I can buy you
know if you go and look at bone broth at
the farmers's market it looks expensive
and I know why that's so expensive so um
so I am fully in support of uh of the
acidified foods being available for home
production uh I would uh and I'm glad
that it does not include the low asset
okay representative Duty uh yes thank
you madam chair I just want to be clear
so this amendment it replaces the entire
bill that's correct okay thank you y any
other comment I'd like to call the rooll
on um amend amend this amendment uh
thank you madam chair this is to adopt
Amendment 202
44738 for House Bill 1565 representative
kraton hi represent ktoa yes
representative Moffet I represent Davis
yes represent Bean yes represent kouan
yes represent Brown yes represent Penza
yes represent smart yes represent Bixby
yes represent sopus yes represent dsy
yes represent Murray yes represent Jama
yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
moris yes represent bman yes Madam chair
yes the amendment is adopted 20 thank
you and do I hear a motion for
otpa yes M yes Madam chair I'd like to
make a motion for otpa on hb50 and 65
thank you any second I'll second that
thank you representative Bixby
uh do I hear um would you like to speak
to your motion at all I think I'm good
all right good uh I think we're done
with that conversation so I'd like to
have the clerk call the rooll on that
thank you madam chair this is uh as otpa
on House Bill 1565 representative kraton
I representative ktoa yes representative
Moffet I represent Davis yes represent
Bean yes represent kulon yes represent
Brown yes represent Penza
yes represent smart represent Bixby yes
represent
siketus yes represent Duty represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard represent NAB
yes represent Morris yes repres Bushman
yes Madam chair yes 20 Z thank
you and that
leaves uh well yes uh any any objection
to putting it on
consent okay put it on consent thank you
uh last one hb1
1185 um which
is
the
sorry 1685 uh I'm sorry 1685 redefining
Homestead Foods as Artisan Foods
creating an artisan food operations
exemption establishing Artis and food
products sales venues and allowing the
production and sale of Artis and food
products requiring
Refrigeration um I would like to make a
motion to interim study this bill do I
hear a second U Madam chair I'll second
that representative Murray seconds that
bill and I'll speak to my
motion so we did talk about
um there are some aspects in this
particular
bill um which have some Merit and we
would like to explore
further
how local food
producers May
produce Foods as Homestead or Artisan
Foods
producers in future because we do know
that we do have some constituents that
are interested in being able to produce
things like pumpkin peses custard pies
turkey pot pies chicken pot pies beef
casseroles that kind of thing on their
Farm
stands and we'd like to probably sit
down with um health food and safety
folks and see what we might come up with
for some other
future um legislation that might include
that it might include something where we
require people to take food safety
courses uh in order to do this or
register with Department of Health and
Human Services in order to do this but
but we should explore some of the ways
in which we can um maybe expand food
production for locally produced food as
representative suffi is brought up in uh
in the
testimony uh for reviewing this bill
when covid happened people were were uh
not finding food at the grocery stores
and to be able to have um more expanded
local food opportunities and and have
food
available um would be something that
would be a preferable thing so I think
putting this bill in interim study will
give us the opportunity to really look
at some of the issues and see where we
might be able to make some tweaks or
changes to current law uh to allow those
kinds of activities to happen
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and I I I also want to concur with
your thoughts but I also so want to make
sure that in supporting the inter room
study that we are having the opportunity
to bring some of those Artisan
stakeholders and small um small
producers uh homesteaders whatever we're
calling them uh to the table and have
this conversation in ways that we have
both the department and the you know um
Community stakeholders involved in a way
that uh we feel it's workable and can
move forward towards um diversifying our
food options absolutely that's the
intention representative sofikitis I'd
like to V unteer if it passes to be on
that committee I'll be looking for
volunteers representative Duty yes thank
you madam chair
um this bill has eaten away at me for a
long time and I've been thinking about
it and um the reason is is because from
my business background I see this as a
bill to deregulate business and it's
masking as a food safety Bill okay so I
mean you know we've seen in this
legislation no regulations for anybody
that does anything that has to do with
with home food preparation so my
question would be what happens and and I
come from a long history of um
shopkeepers entrepreneurs who are in the
in the food industry my great great
grandfather uh made uh sausages my
grandfather uh ran a corner store my uh
cousin owns a meat market and in all of
these cases they supplement their income
uh by by making prepared foods okay so
in a bill like this or a future bill
that you want to look at what prevents
Holly Homemaker from setting up shop
across the street from a corner store
okay and making prepared sandwiches egg
salad H ham salad the whole nine yards
okay and selling them at reduced prices
because she has no employees she has has
no overhead she has no nothing and you
know I'm not sure that there's safety
things um you know in that it has really
taken in
consideration um you know people in the
cities who are working at low margins I
mean their their job Food Service
doesn't have a lot of high margin you
know products uh and they could be
harmed by this so that would be my
question I think that that's a
consideration something to explore when
we do this in St absolutely I mean what
is the dynamic that would occur
representative Murray um thank you madam
chair and and and to the members point I
would I would like to say that I think
that that's all the more reason that I
support the inter room study having
worked previously with the Department on
mushroom harvesting and foraging and
finding a pathway to allow folks to
safely do that and be able to get their
product and to retail establishments
that is my goal is making sure that we
see um and there were things that's were
stood up for folks to attend classes and
participation and I'm not saying that's
necessarily 100% the right model but I I
fully support the interim study to get
to that place okay good representative
Duty yes thank you madam chair I just
have one last question you know and that
is um uh representative attenza said
that you know the bills that come
forward should be to solve a problem and
and I agree I mean every bill that we
look at should start with what's the
problem what's the issue what are we
trying to address and you know I've
scratched my head a number of times and
I've said this before we throw away 330
million tons of food a year none of this
food is going to go to you know
underprivileged or people who you know
are food deprived right now so who is
this bill meant to serve and what
problem is it meant to
solve thank you for your question
representative Howard thank you madam
chair um I have a little bit of an
answer to representative dut's question
um there I have several con constituents
in my district who have asked me to vote
for these bills because because they are
limited in what they can offer and and
it is a a good part of their income that
sustains them them through the year so
there there that's who needs it and and
we are an hon ENT preneurial State and I
think that within the the boundaries of
safe delivery of food I think we should
we should examine this representative
Penza I'd like to piggyback on the
statements that representative sfus made
when we discussed this during our work
session because I think what she said
about community and um and what took
place during uh during covid was um was
really valid in building that Community
this is not it's more more so than just
about people being able to have some
extra income I really believe that food
and sourcing is really important and I
think that it starts in your local
community thank you okay I'd like to
direct the uh clerk to call a rooll on
motion of interim study for hb1 um sorry
1685 thank you madam chair motion is
interim study representative
kraton I represent coma yes represent
Moffett hi represent Davis yes represent
Bean yes represent kulon yes represent
Brown yes represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent
sopitas yes represent Duty no represent
Murray yes represent ger yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB yes represent moris no represent
bman yes Madam chair yes
182 interim study okay uh so the
question is is can it go on consent or
is it going to be a minority I think it
I think it can't go on consent
because well no because it's essentially
your microphone please if it's if it's
20 to Zer or 19 to1 and that one says
yeah that's fine consent is fine then
then I think that's acceptable but I
think that if that that that this
doesn't quite meet that margin and it's
up to the people who voted know whether
they want to do a Minority Report would
you like a to put it on
consent I'll do you do a Minority Report
okay all right um we are done with our
executing our bills I'm going to call it
I want to first thank our uh substitutes
for sitting in all morning and
representative NAB you have a uh comment
um I have a question having been in the
minority on the bill
um 1182 if it can go on consent we sort
of jumped to not putting it on consent
but I think the three of us that voted
in the minority are fine with it going
on
consent anyone said if you're fine with
it going on consent then go for it okay
we are thank you okay
okay 182 correct yes okay thank you
that's
fine Madam chair yes ma'am yeah I will
we consider and put that on consent the
last bill which 1685 right we can put
that on consent okay good
enough
right
yes all right thank you and um so we
have to be back here by one
o'clock and I wish you a good
lunch thank you
everyone
was
for
and
H and El's not here to introduce the
bill so I'm going
to
oh I'm going to ask ask committee
members to please take their seats and
we can get underway with a public
hearing for HB
1327 um I don't know where
representative Davis oh he stepped out
right yeah he'll be back in 15 minutes
okay we got for HB
1327 and this is relative to the
definition of farmers
markets
so um
I had gotten
um communication from representative
Elward uh I forget when but she sent me
an email
um a couple weeks ago or two weeks ago
saying that she had made an error in uh
her understanding of um the farmers
market and wished for us to itl this
bill um because she had already passed
the time where the bill could be
withdrawn and so in terms of IND
introducing we have to int formally
introduce the bill uh which is relative
to the definition of farmers markets but
um in Defence to her um her desire to
have this bill
ited uh I'm going to ask that the
committee
um
itl the bill representative Murray thank
you madam chair I just for procedural
question we open close the hearing and
then are we doing that another time or
immediately no I I will close the
hearing and then we can go through and
do the exec on the bill
okay so if anybody has any questions
about this particular bill um I would
then elect to close the
hearing so I'll close the hearing
on HB
1327 and I would like to open up um an
exec session on HB
1327 and I would like to uh make a
motion to itl Second this
bill with a second from representative
Bixby and then I would ask um the clerk
to call the
role
thank you madam chair so the motion is
itl and hp1
1327 representative kraton I
representative ktoa yes
representative
kulan representative Davis yes sorry
about that representative Penza yes
represent smart represent Bixby yes
represent sopus yes represent Duty yes
represent Murray yes represent Jama yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
yes represent NAB yes represent moris
yes bman yes Madam chair
yes
17 Z motion to itl is adopted thank you
and without
um excuse me without any
um can we put this on
consent thank
you
yes and uh I I'll I'll write make sure
it's really detailed I will write I will
write the thing on it the blurb
whatever okay
um that brings us to HB
1386 which is relative to prohibiting
the disposal of lithium ion batteries in
solid waste landfill facilities
composting facilities or incinerators
and with that we have our distinguished
representative evil to introduce this
bill yeah well thank yeah thank you very
much and happy to be here before what
might be my favorite committee but
anyways um uh my name is Karen eel and I
represent um marac district 7 which is
New London and Newbury and I'm here to
introduce um HB
1386 which would prohibit the um the
disposal of lithium ion batteries in
solid waste landfills and
incinerators it would also um update the
definition of electronic waste which is
already banned from disposal in the
state of New Hampshire um what you have
before you is an amendment it's a
replace all amendment that that's why I
gave it to you guys I thought um you do
have the bill but I there were some
changes made based on conversations with
some of the stakeholders which I wanted
to go through the um through with the
committee um I'm going to keep my
comments relatively brief because
there's a great deal of interest and
support um for this bill from folks that
work with these issues on a day-to-day
basis and I want to give them time to
make their comments um this bill I'm
bringing forward to you as the chair of
the solid waste working group which is
the Statewide um stakeholder group that
works with Dees and stakeholders on
issues of solid waste um when we
discussed uh What
legislation uh we would be supporting
this year uh I asked the group and two
hands went up immediately and then more
and I said okay well what's on your mind
and they said lithium batteries and the
primary problem with them is that they
present a great fire hazard they are
also obviously uh valuable materials
they really should be
recycled um and reused to the extent
possible and they also are toxic if they
get into our waist stream so from the
standpoint of our newly adopted Solid
Waste Management plan um the Banning of
lithium iron batteries from disposal and
the expansion or updating of the
electronic waste um the electronic waste
definition both support the um the solid
waste management plan reducing toxicity
in the waste stream and increasing
safety for Public Works
employees um as I said I am going to
keep my comments somewhat to a minimum
because the folks that are here to
testify on the bill can make a very
strong case as to why uh it's a good
thing to ban um the disposal of lithium
ion batteries um what I wanted to just
go through the amendment so it's amend
that I'm suggesting to the committee for
its consideration it's amendment number
04978 um which I passed out to you folks
and basically what this amendment does I
also gave you the the related statute
there in the related statute which you
have a copy of um section Roman numeral
2 is what I was proposing to add lithium
batteries to section four is the section
that Roman numeral 4 is the section that
establishes the banon electronic w
um and rather than just leaving them as
separate Provisions what I did was in my
Amendment on line six on the first page
is I basically combined uh the two
Provisions into one so it says no person
shall dispose of wet Cell lithium ion or
batteries or electronic devices in a
landfill or an incinerator and that
basically just picks up language that's
already in in statute
so in subsection B this is the provision
in particular that I wanted to talk to
the committee about if you look on at
the statute which I gave you um for the
ban on disposal of ye leaf and yard
waste and the ban on disposal of
electronic waste there's what we would
call a hold harmless Clause that
basically says that if the landfill uh
operator or an incinerator operator
provide informational signs to folks
telling them of the ban and notifying
them that they shouldn't be dumping you
can't hold the landfill liable for an
inappropriate disposal in the landfill
and so what uh um the solid waste folks
asked uh Waste Management in cassella in
particular is if the if the hold
harmless Clause couldn't also apply to
batteries um I've included that in this
amendment um I think that makes a lot of
sense I mean you can't hold a landfill
operator strictly liable because
somebody they know not who threw a
lithium battery in the thing so I just
thought that that was self-evident the
other thing that I put in here that I
actually am excited about and this is
supported by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um it calls for for towns
Solid Waste districts and owners or
operators of the landfill facilities or
incinerators it calls upon them to make
educational materials um available on
Safe Handling and Recycling and that can
be accomplished very simply by just
putting a link on their websites it's
it's really and um there are plenty of
websites out there from the EPA to um
some other folks that will be testifying
before so that is an easy thing to do
and um it also
encourages uh these entities to provide
recycling opportunities for the
batteries when they can I think this
just helps everyone because you really I
mean from an insurance standpoint from
the standpoint of harm to your employees
you really want to keep these things out
of out of the hopper and and being
handled um safely and then the next part
of the bill is the same as HB 138 which
you had originally um the only thing is
that on line 26 inadvertently omitted
was video display media recorder player
which is a defined term in our statutes
and it just wasn't included in the
definition of electronic device this
section hadn't really been updated since
the early
2000s and um you know a lot has happened
with technology since that time and
looking around at other states and
looking at the definition that we had I
just um I updated it it's obviously
somewhat of an expansion because it had
to expand to include technology that
didn't exist 25 years ago and I did make
some obvious exclusions from that so
with that I'll conclude my testimony I
just want to say that uh waste
management cassella New Hampshire
Municipal
Association the national waste and
recycling Association the department of
safety conservation law Foundation New
Hampshire Association of Fire Chiefs um
those are all folks that I'm aware of um
and there may be others that are
supporting this measure and are really
pleased to have it brought
forward thank you representative eel I
have to commend you for um putting this
together and getting all of the
stakeholders uh together to be aware of
this um and I'm I'm happy happy to have
been a co-sponsor of this Bill thank you
very much anybody representative
Penza so my question has to do with just
the education piece of this for um you
know
consumers what is the gauge of the level
of awareness of not realizing to put
these batteries you know just in their
trash because of course you've got the
small lithium rechargeable ones right
and then you have you know bigger ones
that would be you know you know hard to
necessarily put just like in your
regular
trash well there's a representative here
from uh the national resources Recovery
Association she works with uh
municipalities all across the state so
she might be able to answer that uh
better than I can um I think there's
been a lot of effort at transfer
stations and at municipalities to just
be like hammering away on the fact that
people shouldn't be disposing of these
things
um you know like anything it takes time
and one of the effects I hope of this
bill is it continues to raise the level
of awareness especially about these
lithium ion batteries um I mean I was
talking to a constituent recently they
they ride ebikes and they have these
lithium batteries and they have no idea
what to do with them and I just said
we're working on that um and I think
it's in the interest of towns to make it
as easy as possible for people to bring
these batteries to the transfer stations
or tell them what to do with them um in
the long run because they should be
recycled but they also cause fires and
we have somebody here that can talk
personally about a fire they had in
their town thank you representative eil
now I as I understand Dees has on their
website um a whole list of different
kinds of materials and how to dispose of
them right will lithium ion batteries be
included in that or are they now I I I
mean somebody from the Department is
here I believe they have a batteries a
whole battery section okay that you can
you can use that I know nrra has a
batteries tool kit they have all sorts
of things on their website and um the
EPA also has information so it's just
you know this is part of what what I
hope becomes a common practice in towns
to have a section of their website that
talks about way waste reduction and
solid waste and this could easily be a
trigger or incorporated into whatever
they already have thank you
representative marray thank you madam
chair um and thank you uh representative
eel for bringing this forward with
regards to line 13 and 14 regarding
posting informational signs at the
facility um do you imagine that it would
also um municipalities might find a
resource or a partner in some some
entity like New Hampshire the beautiful
or some other entity that could help
them put that signage up there as well
yeah I I hope they do I mean in in the
case of my town they just have like
poster board you know but um I mean the
again these things are so hazardous it
just anything that the town can sort of
get out there at a transfer station or
whatever to catch people's attention it
would be all to the
good representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair um and thank you
representative for taking my question do
we know what's happening to them now is
that what we're going to hear more about
I think you'll be hearing okay more um I
I just think we can do a lot better
and I guess I would say that I think a
lot of transfer stations are really
working hard now to make sure that these
things stay out of the wa stream but
what I heard in at the solid waste
working group and in general is that we
really need to put a little more teeth
into the situation to give them
something to point to to to enable them
to do be even better than they are thank
you any other questions representative
Bosman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question
representative I know in here it talks a
little bit about about increasing the
availability of places to deposit all of
these items do you have any sense of to
what extent we would be able to do that
as well I'm thinking education is one
side the awareness but if we don't have
enough places that are convenient enough
then it won't happen so how do you see
this bill speaking to that um again
someone is here from nrra and she can
speak a little bit more about systems
that are already in place but um because
I anticipated this question I looked at
a um a website from a company called
call to recycle which um I know towns
are already using and there's actually
information on there you can put in your
location and they can tell you the
nearest place that you can bring um
bring your batteries and what I saw was
Home Depot I I know and then with
electronic way waste um you can bring it
I mean this is what I've done I just
bring it to Best Buy and they take it
and then they re for free and then they
recycle
it this is not a paid um advertisement
representative Bixby yeah um I'm just
wondering what sort of enfor enforcement
Provisions there are if
any um well I asked the department that
this morning and um it's the enforcement
provision that uh appli appes to any
provision that's in 149 M um and that is
149 M5 and 16 and so even though that
provision isn't specifically called out
in many of the statutes or Provisions
under 149 M that is the standard
enforcement language that the department
uses for administrative uh enforcement
and if they need to turn it to the AG
for criminal sanctions
um since I we don't have that right in
front of us can you give us a brief
summary of what that looks like what I
would do is defer to the department to
give that to you I mean I actually I I
noticed that in 149
m273 which I gave you the copy of the
statute does specifically say it's
enforcable under 149 M5 and 16 and so
one of the reasons I asked the
department the question is I said well
just because if you don't specifically
mention it isn't that the provision that
you use to enforce these things and they
said yes so maybe when they wrote The
Leaf and yard waste provision they
wanted to do a little belt and
suspenders operation but it's really not
necessary to be in there thank you okay
any other questions for representative
evil seeing none thank you so much for
bringing this to our committee sure
thank thank you and I would like now to
call
Garrett
Trier
[Music]
sorry from Waste
Management good afternoon and welcome to
environment
agriculture please put your mic on there
you go that good that's it thank you
you're live thank you madam chair um my
name is Garrett triler I'm director of
public affairs for Waste Management uh
waste management is the leading provider
provider of Environmental Services in uh
North America um in New Hampshire we
operate the turnkey recycling
environmental Enterprise in Rochester we
have four transfer stations a recycling
facility and 200 uh waste and recycling
collection trucks that operate
throughout the state so issues like this
we certainly um get very involved when
there's issues that will impact the
industry I'm very happy to be here in
support today of uh House Bill
1386 um as has been discussed uh lithium
ion batteries are a form of rechargeable
batteries that can be bought
individually or also contained in quite
a few uh electronic devices uh all the
way up to as well as up to cars um um
when disposed of improperly these
batteries can be very problematic for
waste transfer stations and recycling
facilities um mostly uh in fact EPA
determined that most uh lithium ion
batteries on the market are likely to be
hazardous wastes when they are disposed
of because they can catch fire explode
if not handled
carefully and to that point uh several
of our facilities in New Hampshire have
faced impacts from in improper uh
handling of these batteries uh in 2023
we experienced Fires at our recycle
Rochester recycling facility one that
almost destroyed the entire building and
we had two fires at our Auburn transfer
station La that year as well several
years ago a fire at our Laconia transfer
station um completely uh destroy the
building uh requiring it to be out of
service for quite a while and cost
upwards of $100,000 to repair um this is
only a literally a few examples I I
cover the New England and New York area
and we were having issues all throughout
not just our region but all throughout
the country our industry trade
Association the national waste and
recycling Association recently released
a port a report I'm sorry that estimates
that more than 5,000 fires annually just
in recycling facilities alone they
didn't even study transfer stations
which is also a major problem um n did
uh submit testimony uh via your online
system so you should have their
testimony as well as a copy of that
report um which has a lot of other
really detailed information about the
costs not just to the facilities not
just to the facility operators but in
fire departments and and the like and
certainly in Insurance um and I would
also note that it's anticipated that the
use of these types of batteries is only
going to increase very very greatly over
the next 5 10 years so unless things
like these bills are passed um these
issues are going to continue um I would
also just like to to quickly mention um
we did get a copy of the amendment and I
do think a real critical component of
this is the educational aspect um the
ban is great I think it helps have that
conversation with folks um but also um
knowing where these batteries exist uh
are also very important I would liken it
a little bit to the effort that was
undertaken over the number of years on
Mercury containing products um
especially in areas where waste of
energy is prevalent um so I think it can
be done it's just going to take some
time and I think we all should work
together so happy to support the
legislation I can take any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Kwa thank you
madam chair and thank you for being here
and taking my question of
course right now there is no legislation
Banning lithium batteries but as you
privately own landfills
can't you ban them yourselves well we
can we do work with our customers so we
do try to educate our customers to that
point um I think having a ban helps that
messaging a bit because then there's you
know some potential like we said maybe
some enforcement action on that so
there's nothing preventing us from
educating our customers which we will
continue to do um we also are only a one
player here so I think you know all
companies I think we are doing that I
mean we absolutely if you go on our
website we do have plenty of information
about how to recycle properly not just
on lithium ion batteries but a whole
host of issues so the answer is we can
do that and we will continue to do that
I do think having this law would would
help that thank you any other questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
so much for coming today appreciate it
i' like to call Reagan
biset Northeast research Recovery
Association good
afternoon good good afternoon thank you
madam chair I also have copies of my
testimony if you'd like me to sure just
pass them around appreciate
it so and before you start I'm just
going to uh let the committee know I
will be leaving shortly uh because I
have to introduce a bill of mine in
another committee and I will leave you
in the very capable hands of
Representative kraton so thank you
my name is Reagan Binet I'm the
executive director of the Northeast
resource recovery Association we are a
nonprofit that works with about 90% of
the communities here in New Hampshire to
help them manage their own recycling
programs um organization doesn't take a
position on this bill simply because we
don't engage in lobbying but I am here
to just share some information about our
members experience with lithium ion
batteries and and electronics
recycling one thing I'd like to mention
is that the uh this bill is consistent
with one of the action items in the New
Hampshire Solid Waste Management plan
the Department of Environmental Services
issued its most recent Solid Waste
Management plan in October of
2022 and that plan identifies ways to uh
reduce waste being disposed of in the
state and also improve waste production
and Recycling and there is a specific
action
2.10 that encourage the encourages the
exploration of legislation to establish
waste disposal bands for items including
rechargeable
batteries you already heard about some
of the uh reasons why lithium ion
batteries are dangerous and costly for
facilities we as an organization are
certainly hearing more and more from our
member communities about fires that
there experiencing at their transfer
stations and I'd like to provide just a
few examples that have come up in recent
years so in June of 2020 the city of
keen transfer station had a fire they
suspected it was caused by something
improperly disposed of certainly could
have been a lithium ion battery um but
in many cases it's difficult to
ultimately determine what causes these
fires but in that case a firefighter
experienced a back injury from that fire
there was considerable damage to their
transfer station that had to be
repaired um nearby in Portland Maine in
uh January 2021 the recycling nonprofit
Ecom main had a lithium ion battery fire
at their facility fortunately they were
able to resume operations the next day I
think you'll be hearing from the town of
Lee and a lithium ion battery that they
had uh in May of
2022 in May of 2023 Bart New Hampshire
had a fire at their transfer station
caused by an electric bike
battery and they were able to quickly
contain that fire with no
injuries and then one more example in
August of 2023 over in our neighboring
Vermont Alva was service had a fire at
their transfer station that they thought
was most likely from a lithium ion
battery um and one thing I wanted to
point out is that these batteries don't
typically just sort of spontaneously
combust on their own the real issue is
when they're not properly recycled and
they end up uh in the trash and you've
got heavy equipment that is moving trash
or driving over material and it's when
those batteries get punctured that then
they can cause a fire um so some of the
questions that came up from the
committee um one was how aware people
are of this issue I would say that
they're certainly not aware enough I
mean we're seeing more and more of these
fires um we're certainly seeing more and
more recharging lithium ion batteries
being used in uh electronics and other
devices and so it's really important
that we do whatever can be done to um
increase public awareness and on that
note uh I did want to share that one of
the things that is currently happening
with batteries and other electronics
right now is that there are a number of
options for communities to properly
recycle those materials so the nor East
resource recovery Association works with
um a variety of different recycling
companies in New Hampshire and New
England and that includes working with a
number of electronics recycling
companies that also can accept uh
batteries
from uh communities in New Hampshire so
there are options and outlets for
properly managing that
material uh typically that's handled at
the municipal level where residents can
often bring their batteries or their
Electronics to their local transfer
station and then the transfer station
can properly um send that material to
get
recycled our organization also provides
a lot of educational material geared
towards both uh Municipal transfer
station staff and residents we have a
batteries recycling toolkit on our
website and one of the things it
includes is a poster that communities
can download and print for free that
explain explains how to properly uh
manage and recycle different types of
batteries and that's been pretty popular
and certainly if this law gets passed
our organization would be very happy to
work with the Department of
Environmental Services to help provide
any supportive uh developing any
additional signage or other materials
that might be useful to post- at
transfer stations or share with
residents um for example we're actually
working right now with a nonprofit
called New Hampshire the the beautiful
and they provide free uh facility
recycling signage for transfer stations
in New Hampshire and we're actually
working with them right now on reviewing
and modernizing a lot of the signage
that they offer for municipalities so
certainly um uh updated signage
regarding waste bands including a ban on
lithium ion batteries is something that
we would be happy to assist
with so if anyone has any questions I'd
be happy to answer them representa right
thank you Mr chair um so thank you for
taking my question so can in talking
about the varying size of lithium
batteries and lithium ion batteries they
can go from being as small as something
like a coin or a button battery all the
way to car um so in which case I do you
see there being a lot of consumer and
education that needs to happen to say
that yes these these small button coin
things also go into this sort of
conversation or I mean ideally yes
ideally we'd have a nationwide consumer
education campaign around this because
of the dangers of these rechargeable
batteries and and as you said they can
vary from very very small I mean often
even if consumer wants to properly
manage these it can be difficult for
example uh if you've got um shoes little
kids shoes that have lights in them or
toys sometimes you can't even get them
there's no way to open them to get to
the rechargeable battery inside so it
can be increasingly difficult for
residents it's confusing so um the more
education the better on this
issue just ma'am I have a I do have a
question in terms of scope and so you
talked about the transfer stations
having this capability to recycle
lithium batteries
what's your assessment on does 100% of
transportations have that 50% or where
are we at with that even at the Town
level I don't have an exact number on
that but what I would say is I know it's
not 100% of Municipal transfer stations
that accept electronics and batteries
but I would say it's certainly more than
50% it's very common that towns offer
that as a service to their
residents
and how many
recycling facilities do you have in the
state so how easy is it for the transfer
station then to move that on to an
appropriate recycling point so at least
for the the transfer stations that are
working with our organization one of the
things we do is we make it as easy as
possible to manage those Logistics of
getting material to the ultimate
recycling company uh I can think of
three or four different different
companies that we work with that are
based in New Hampshire that do battery
electronics recycling um one specific
example is universal recycling
Technologies has a large facility in
Dober where they actually um manage a
lot of electronics and and do some
recycling right there at the facility so
we do have options within the state okay
thank you representative BX so uh our
lithium batteries one of the items that
uh
that a re a transfer station can sell at
a profit or to the company that's taking
them or is this one that that costs to
get rid of it's It's currently typically
at a cost so one of the challenges for
communities is say if a municipality had
a very large quantity of lithium ion
batteries maybe if they had enough of
that material there could be an outlet
where they actually could get paid a bit
of money for that but when you take into
account relatively small amounts um the
necessity to be trucking this material
somewhere and the hall fees associated
with that communities are typically
having to pay to dispose of those
materials properly and so in some cases
they might uh charge a fee to Residents
um and I believe also um someone from
the town of Lee can speak a little bit
more to that situation follow up please
uh so is the amount that is the is that
fee amount
I there are some things that will cost
um a certain amount to dispose of but
that amount would be lower than the
amount of a tipping fee is that do or is
this would lithium ion batteries fall
into the this is cheaper than a tipping
fee or this is more expensive than a
tipping fee or are they just so light
that it doesn't it's sort of hard to
calculate they're typically so small
that it is sort of negligible um unless
you're dealing with the the car
batteries okay thanks and represent Mar
uh thank you Mr chair what to that end
for the larger batteries there are
dealerships that often times will do
recovery of those types of very large
batteries um themselves um do you see
this um do you see the opportunity for
more of those types of recapture
opportunities happening even outside of
just transfer
stations well certainly I think transfer
stations would be happy if the batteries
were going somewhere else so if if a car
dealership will take back um electric
batteries from cars that's certainly
preferable um there's currently not as
many outlets for recycling that material
um so they're a bit more difficult for
transfer stations to
manage I would say in terms of you know
you're getting into sort of extended
producer responsibility uh if there was
some requirement to make the producers
the manufacturers of these materials
actually Ensure that they can be uh
responsibly recycled in a you know
financially viable way that's certainly
one option to deal with the
problem any further
questions thank you so much for your
testimony thank you I'd like to call Mr
Steve I believe this is
Butler is that correct or am
I what go ahead my last name's bulock
can you spell please b u l l e k okay
thank
you yes sir so I'm from the town of Lee
I'm the Public Works director we had a
fire in our facility in May of a couple
years ago we are in support of this
bill uh I'd
say if a 100 batteries come into the
facility we might recycle 50 of them we
pull them out of the waist stream all
the time time and then bring them up
there's we've had numerous close
calls but yeah I'm in support of the
bill it mainly came in case you had
questions there
potential the batteries that you're
pulling out are they um are they
small some are some a lot of them are
power tool batteries like Milwaukee
batteries old DeWalt
batteries oh like the ones that attach
to that's 90% of what we do the fire at
our facility was actually started by a
laptop computer battery someone got a
new battery threw the old one out and it
still had a charge in it and the Machine
pinched it and it arked out on the
bucket and caused a
fire I'd say from when it started
smoking to when the bucket was
completely engulfed in flames was 30
seconds so it happens fast
follow up yes ma'am would you say the
greatest problem that we have is is
education in the public for not
realizing to the yeah I mean so they go
all the way down to greeting cards you
have a greeting card you open up and it
plays music or lights up that's a
lithium battery that's oh my gosh I
forgot about
those oh my
gosh okay any other questions
representative Murray uh thank you uh Mr
Sharon thank you for taking my question
I appreciate you being here today
because I think this is an important
conversation that we are having I think
the previous speaker mentioned those um
items that have stuff in beded in them
that are coins or or button batteries
yes um what do you see um as far as
getting those types of things out of the
waist room how is that possible or do
you just education and pictures okay
because a lot of people don't think of
it thank
you all right uh represent Penza one
more sorry for you the
world so
um so you said just of course getting
them out would be there's an education
piece but what would people that's
something that is not like a traditional
like the greeting card right that's not
a traditional
um uh recyclable P like what would
people do with them
then so what we would do if we find them
in the mixed paper bin is we take him
out take the B battery out and then
recycle it like we would all the other
stuff so you just have to take it apart
okay
perfect all right thank you sir really
appreciate your
testimony I'd like to call Brian Allard
please good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Brian Allard I'm
the assistant director with the New
Hampshire State Fire Marshalls Office
I'm Marsh to me apologizes he couldn't
be here today he did submit a written
testimony ahead of time and I'll just
read through that uh for you uh so
lithium ion fires uh are certainly a
growing concern across our country uh
the use of lithium ion batteries
increases year-over-year
a particular concern is the speed and
fire growth um and the excessive amount
of heat that is released from those
fires and in the intensity of those
fires uh lithium ion batteries can
experienced thermal runaway uh which can
result in overheating flaming and some
cases explosion of the batteries uh
significant work is underway to study uh
these types of issues um back in
November of 2023 there's a national
campaign uh charge of battery safe
campaign so that the charge stands for
choose certified
products handle lithium ion battery
powered devices with care always stay
alert and uh of warning signs recycle
devices and batteries properly uh get
out if there is a fire and finally
educate others on the best practice
which is the message that we're hearing
today from the others who have testified
uh so we certainly support this bill and
the proper recycling of of these
batteries and I'm here for any questions
if you have any any
questions seeing none thank you sir
appreciate your
testimony and I'd like to call Michael
no nor
okay please thank
you please turn on your
microphone thank you awesome uh thank
you for uh allowing the opportunity to
testify on uh HB 1386 for the record my
name is Michael norc uh I am
representing the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services uh
Solid Waste Management
Bureau um this bill as I can't really
add much to the comments that were
already provided by other folks uh that
testified previously uh other than to
say you know this is an important issue
uh Recycling and and proper management
of uh lithium ion batteries uh and as as
well as proper management of electronic
devices um to the extent that you know
proper management of these items reduces
toxicity of the waste stream uh and
increases safety at Solid Waste
Management facilities and also supports
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services um the solid
waste management plan that we have
developed uh as was noted by Miss Bess
Binet from
nrra
um with that being said we do support
the intent of this bill we cannot take a
position on this specific bill um but we
do recognize that proper management of
these batteries is of particular
importance for safety and for all the
reasons that were noted previously
um I'm just going to address a couple
questions that I I noticed the uh the
committee already brought up I believe
is representative Bixby had asked about
enforcement
Provisions I'll just say representative
Bisby I am not an expert on those
provisions of the statute but I'm happy
to provide you that language I can send
you a link to that if that would satisfy
you I can probably find it online thanks
okay okay
um there was also a question about what
online resources exist uh and what Dees
has already produced um Dees has posted
a website that has a large uh variety of
different waste types that are listed
and information on proper management and
Recycling and Disposal uh for home
owners businesses schools um and we do
have a page that's devoted specifically
to batteries um because they are there's
so many different types of batteries
there's so many different uh
chemistries uh and one thing that I just
wanted to note for the committee in some
of the comments that have been
um made so far I think there might be a
little bit of confusion about lithium
ion batteries versus lithium batteries
and I I can understand the confusion
because they both exist lithium
batteries tend to be non-rechargeable uh
they tend to be like the Button cell
batteries or uh the things that are in
the greeting cards um those batteries
because they have lithium chemistry do
pose fire risk uh lithium ion batteries
on the other hand uh are rechargeable
batteries so they're the kind that are
you know associated with power tools
laptops cell phones on and on and on I
mean they're ubiquitous uh and they just
seem to be a growing sector of uh the
electric devices that we use these days
um I just wanted to note that for the
Committees just for your edification
that this bill would ban disposal of
lithium ion batteries however it would
not under under as I read it would not
ban disposal of lithium batteries um so
just to clarify that for the committee
um and with that I'm happy to take any
questions J
boan bman thank you no problem it's new
thank you uh Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so my first question
I think I share it um is why sorry why
aren't lithium batteries a part of it or
or would would we want to add that would
that fit in there uh does it make sense
to include that is what I'm
asking uh that's not something I think
the department had considered prior to
me just being here and realizing that
there was some you know you know in the
conversation there was some confusion
between these different types of
batteries um that is something that I
think the committee could consider um
it's it's not not something that I had
previously uh thought of followup yes
ma'am thank you sir um so there is a you
would say there is a benefit to it then
I would say that lithium batteries pose
a fire risk the same that lithium ion
batteries do but they're smaller so
they're not as um you know they they
don't tend to they don't tend to be the
the offenders necessarily in terms of
causing fires but they do if you have
enough of them you could potentially I
think the question is they shouldn't be
put in the in the solid waste stream
correct regular lithium batteries I
think best management practice would
you're correct would be to separately
manage them so that they're not mixed in
with other refu and going into into
disposal at landfills or incinerators
follow up yes ma'am so if if you get the
bill in front of you it says
it has lithium on it and then it has
Dash and that and that's ion so that
could be taken as both couldn't
it um I think in terms of how I'm sorry
was that a question for me yeah sorry I
think in terms of how the terminology is
used in the industry lithium ion is a
specific batter battery chemistry so
you'd have to add lithium as a line item
on
here uh to to clar yeah if you wanted to
clarify to to cover those other types of
lithium batteries yes
okay
sure thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh so there's the
possibility that you know perhaps an
amendment might be entertained that
would allow us to distinguish between
these two and include both of them uh in
in a ban but I would also imagine that
this is something that should be worked
into the educational material uh right
because if you're talking about lithium
batteries in greeting cards for example
uh even though that is not a li ium ion
battery which is explicitly covered by
this legislation I would think it should
certainly be an educational material
that is provided to encourage people to
remove lithium ion lithium batteries um
you know whenever they can before
disposing of the
packaging uh yeah that's a good point
and um I I just want to add that
education around batteries is it can be
super confusing for the public because
you may have a button battery that looks
the same as another button battery but
they both have very different chemistry
so it's just very confusing to really um
to know what you're dealing with and so
education is always going to be key um
and that's something that I think the
department can definitely continue to
improve on uh continue to try to
disseminate information we can work with
Partners like
nrra um I I think there's always
opportunity to improve our educational
resources thank
you do I I have a a question
that this all makes sense to me you know
listening to testimony understanding the
environmental impacts the safety fire
impacts why would we not approve this I
mean there might be a cost at some towns
that aren't doing it today that's it
should be um outside of that why would
we not do
this um that's a great question I
I I'm not really prepared to speak to
that uh I guess
yeah I okay it's it's an important
safety issue that's that's one thing I
can say cool thank you yes ma'am has the
department ever
considered because most of these things
like you put it on a website you um you
know you put signage of course at a um
you
know um at the dump or um at a what's
transfer station or something like that
so why not like something that's more
publicly visible has the department ever
thought of doing education campaigns
like they do on other health related
things like Billboards and stuff like
that because that's what people see
you're driving like I just I
think I don't know it's very active that
someone has to see a sign or go on to a
website and it's just not common that's
not what everybody's going to do when
they are bringing their trash to the
dump or or having it picked up at their
house yeah um that's a a great Point
representative Potenza I think um the
more visible you can make it the the the
more audience you can reach um I will
note that the department uh has recently
developed a new section the section that
I head up which is materials management
education and planning uh related to you
know managing waste in more preferable
means uh by recycling or diverting it um
that being said we don't have a lot of
resources available to to do things like
posting Billboards or doing radio
campaigns I I think there is U potential
value in that um but at this time we
don't necessarily have the resources to
really pursue those
Avenues okay fair enough thank you sir
appreciate your
testimony lastly I'd like to invite uh
nage Grace
please thank you Mr chair n CES for the
mun Municipal Association we support the
bill we support the bill we support the
amendment submitted by representative
eel and we would also support any
amendment to include lithium batteries
or any other batteries that may cause a
fire um I will not repeat the lengthy
testimony you've already heard today um
I just want to be very clear that um
given the fire risks associated with
these types of batteries um and all of
the sources from IND industry that I've
heard from uh concur that the vast
majority of fires that they can trace
the origin to are caused by these type
of batteries um the cost associated with
dealing with the aftermath of that far
exceeds the cost of
disposal um obviously replacing
buildings um you know replacing
equipment for firefighters all of that
is very expensive it would be much it is
much cheaper to properly dispose of
these than it is to deal with aftermath
of a fire um with that said I'm happy to
take any questions the Comm committee
may
have
questions thank you all right sir thank
you so
much okay
cool what's
that is there anyone else that we missed
on a pin card on
this okay so uh we have 61 in favor
online zero oppos with one neutral and
on the blue sheet we have
three uh in favor of the bill and with
that I close the hearing on HB
1386 and I'll open the hearing on
hb70
1376 relative to prohibiting certain
packaging from carrying the recycle
logo
and I'd like to
call
uh oh okay good and you're introducing
the bill sir beautiful thank you
representative
kapler cap
ly yeah hi uh thank you Mr chairing then
good afternoon Ena committee it's nice
to be back here in front of the UNA
committee I started out here a couple
years ago you see some uh familiar faces
for the record my my name is Tony Kaplan
I'm a representative from marac 8 the
towns of hener Bradford and Warner and
I'm here to speak on HB
1376 um HB 1376 intends to make it
unlawful to Market plastic containers or
bottles in our state is recyclable using
the recycling
logo at issue is the use of the logo
along with the resin number of different
types of plastics according to the final
report of the committee to study
recycling streams and Solid Waste
Management in New Hampshire cons
consumers are often confused by all of
the resin numbers and variations in form
that affect what can and cannot be
recycled in their
Community the placement of the recycling
logo does not accurately represent
recyclability as many Plastics do not
have n markets and are not financially
viable to
recycle in fact only 5% of plastics are
recycled in the US the proportion that
has been declining since 2018 when China
announced it would no longer accept
plastic waste from from Western
countries according to the Federal Trade
commission's green guide to marketing
issued to ensure that claims made about
environmental attributes of products are
truthful and non- deceptive uh quote it
is deceptive to misrepresent directly or
by implication that a product or package
is recyclable a product or package
should not be marketed as recyclable
unless it can be collected separated or
otherwise recovered from the waist
stream through an established recycling
program in other words it's not enough
that a product theoretically is able to
be recycled in ideal conditions there
have to be established programs for
recycling so HB 1376 states that a
person shall not manufacture or
distribute a plastic container or
plastic bottle with a chasing arrow
symbol or label stating that the plastic
consumer good is recyclable unless the
recycling rate for that good or
packaging is
75% American households produce around
51 million tons of plastic waste a year
more than in any other country much of
that is either dumped in landfills or
incinerated often ending up in the ocean
Plastics already contaminate the entire
planet people consume microplastics via
food and water uh as well as by
breathing them in and the particles have
been found in people's blood and bread
and and breast milk all around the world
according to a 2019 study Americans
consider recycling to be more confusing
than understanding their taxes more than
two-thirds of us incorrectly believe
that any plastic item with a recycling
symbol can be
recycled how much plastic is recycled in
New Hampshire according to the 2021
Solid Waste report Dees calculates a
Statewide recycling rate overall of
26% Based on data provided by the
municipalities in the report Dees states
that quote going forward New Hampshire
Dees hopes to be able to collect better
data to produce more comprehensive
estimates for recycling and diversion so
I'm hoping that this legislation on
deceptive recycling claims would be a
Spur to collecting such
data my brief comment on the fiscal note
attached to HB 1376 is if Municipal data
is enough to estimate a Statewide
recycling rate then DS needs to explain
why collection of Municipal data on
plastic recycling compared to data on
the composition of Municipal Way going
to landfills and incinerators would not
be enough to produce a plastic recycling
rate for the various types of plastic in
the state why do we need itemized
recycling rates for every product which
is the Assumption the fiscal n fiscal
note seems to be based on so I'm hoping
somebody uh from the DS will be up here
after me and and somebody gets to ask
that question my guesses were probably
below the national average for plastic
recycling of 5% given that we recycle
overall below the national average of
32% we're at 26% in which case the
recycling logo would be deceptive on all
types of plastic in New New Hampshire 1
through 7 would this legislation kill
off recycling efforts by demanding the
removal of the recycling logo not at all
manufacturers would still be able to
make realistic claims of recyclability
such as a label saying for instance this
product may be recyclable check with
your municipal or state Solid Waste
Authority in summary all the bill is
asking is to protect New Hampshire
consumers from fraudulent and deceptive
marketing this bill is intended to give
consumers in New Hampshire a clear idea
of what they're purchasing when they buy
plastic bottles or containers and to
stop the misleading use of a logo that
benefits the bottom line of the Plastic
industry at the expense of our citizens
and environment public health and the uh
viability of our waste management system
so I'll try to answer any questions if
you have
any oh my gosh everyone
rep representative Jam thank you Mr
chair thank you representative kapan for
your Tes morning for taking my question
I'm going to use an analogy that I think
my my Republican friends will
particularly like President Reagan
saying you know trust but verify isn't
this effectively what we're talking
about we trust that if they're going to
stamp this logo on this material that
they are being truthful but we also need
to be able to verify the truthfulness of
these claims and and we talk a lot about
the importance of education for the
consumer in diverting waste uh
and having these kinds of emblems on the
material is an important part of that so
uh you isn't that really ultimately what
we're asking for here right is that if
somebody is going to make these
assertions to the public through these
brands that we have the ability to
verify the truthfulness of the claim
absolutely that that is basically the
essence of the bill is is you can't make
claims about you know the environmental
attributes of a product if those claims
aren't uh aren't true and then you know
obviously this the correl to that is are
they true or not and um as I said my
guess is that they're not true in New
Hampshire and so that is basically false
advertising and it not only hurts the
consumer but it hurts the environment
and it hurts it hurts the viability of
our waste management system because of
the amount of plastic it allows people
to continue to use and consume a product
because they're believing that it has
attributes that it doesn't thank you
representative Haskins thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question do you Envision
something that would replace this that
would delineate in other words if my
town is um willing to accept at the
transfer station ones twos and
fives but the waste management company
that picks up traum complex only takes
ones and twos right how is the consumer
looking at products going to
determine what that product has in place
of the chasing arrows well right I mean
that that that's the question is is I
mean I'm not trying to to stop you know
recycling obviously I'm in favor of
recycling so what what does a consumer
want to do with the you know this
plethora of of products out there right
now they all have the same label which
is they're they're recyclable and so you
know my suggestion is that maybe we
replace that logo with something that's
a little bit truer such as maybe this
product may be recyclable check with
your local authorities in other words
they can not just assume it's recyclable
go and find out if it is or not thank
you thank you represent
Penza I love the idea of this bill but
the the Practical nature of it is where
I struggle right because I think I've
been saying this forever I used to you
know it depends on where you live and
and what they accept if you know one
town accepts one two two and three and
the other one only accepts you know five
six and seven because all of these
products are made through big huge
corporations mainly and so those things
that are getting stamped or molded in
there would be no way that we could
police this though like well I mean
actually the bill does enable I mean by
having something in statute it would
enable theoretically our attorney
general to take a company to court for
false advertising I mean will the
Attorney General do that I don't know
that's a you know I don't have a crystal
ball but this is just basically an
enabling statute to say hey we can go go
after people who are misleading uh our
our constituents and you know basically
what I'm hoping is that this sends a
signal uh to maybe along with other
states I don't know if other states are
considering similar legislation but it
would definitely send a signal to people
that you you know you may want to think
about doing something other than putting
a false logo on your product
representative NAB well thank you Mr
chairman I'm sorry I waited until you
were on
your well because representative poza
sort of asked my question which was you
know in this committee we um think about
how labeling just in our state
contradicts Federal labeling or labeling
from other states and how that's
actually workable I wonder if you have
talked to anyone and I don't even know
who it would be in the state as to you
know having labeling requirements that
are different from surrounding states or
even from the entire
country yeah I mean that that is a a
good question that's a legal question I
am not prepared to answer that question
um I I think this basically this this
enables our attorney general to go after
companies within our court system within
the you know local Superior Court uh and
uh that is a that is a court case that a
company no matter where their base would
have to reply to
so yeah representative Murray thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
and welcome back to the committee um
it's nice to see to you um I guess to
that end with my colleague sharing the
same um sentiments this is also an
internationally recognized symbol
whether or not I agree with you it's
frustrating sometimes and I hear from
constituents as a parent with kid
products and and various other things I
I I'm constantly frustrated
by what is actually recyclable and what
is not so I do worry a little bit about
sort of that same concept that we're all
sharing um to that end and but I would
also be curious to hear like what what
else would we do then if we have such a
widely recognized
symbol what what would the solution be
well I
mean I I think that's the problem is
that it's so ubiquitous and so widely
recognized and so misleading that it uh
you know it's a problem
um so that would be my suggestion is
to you know say you cannot continue to
use this logo that gives a false
impression of what um you know what
people can do with this with this
product because it's it it really is
practically not recyclable um and so why
should we allow an industry to continue
to label something that's not
true and representative Bixby yeah so um
there's a there's a range of of what is
recyclable and what isn't
recyclable that kind of goes from one to
seven but not in a not in a exact order
of decreasing recyclability but if you
have a bottle that says number one on it
then if you if that bottle gets to a re
gets to the recycling plant it's going
to be pretty close to 100% recyclable if
you get that number seven to recycling
plant probably not so much but it
depends on so many things about the
context I'm not quite sure how you
divide that up and also if we didn't
have those numbers how would we be as
people who Source separate be able to
say what uh you know what do I throw
into the what do I throw into the bin
that the at the transfer station that my
community will get money for and what
should just go into the trash right well
that's up to every Community every
Community has different uh markets that
they're that they have access to so I
mean in my town you know we were uh
recycling all sorts of plastic up until
a few years ago and now we just take
number one and two uh and you know that
there was a transition there where the
the people the transfer station had a
hard time telling people hey you can't
you you can't recycle these anymore take
back your yogurt containers that we're
not recycling those so I mean it is
confusing um as to the as to the number
yeah the statute states that it has to
have a 75% recycling rate and that's a
Statewide rate so it's not in your town
or in my town it's overall in the state
is it reaching a 75% threshold and I
think that's a fair threshold to be able
to say something is actually recyclable
as if 75% of those products are getting
recycled I don't think you have to do it
product by product though I think you
can do it number one number two you know
the one through seven so if you have you
know 80% of number ones are being
recycled then that is a a product that
can have the logo on it but number five
there's only you know 8% of those are
getting recycled they cannot have the
recycling logo on
it represent
comp thank you Mr chair my question is
very simple can I have that copy of your
testimony please I'd be happy I'd be
happy to share that with you
representative U yeah I'll email it to
you I'll email it to the committee and
representative
penzo so I think it's been several years
now but um I remember the like if you
buy a you know let's say it's a box of
um or that's enclosed in plastic and
it's usually number seven like let's say
if it's um pre-prepared Goods cupcakes
or whatever um and that's seven those
are never recyclable so and they have
that symbol I get it um wouldn't it be
better to be to do more of an education
campaign with people so they so it's on
a user end and maybe they're not
purchasing things that are in in those
plastic containers versus because I I
just don't know how you could implement
this just because all of that stuff is
coming you know really without our
control yeah I am not going to deny that
an educa I'm never going to stand
against an any kind of educational
effort I don't think you can wait you
know is this better or worse I'm an all
the above kind of person you know if
you're trying to attack a problem and uh
throw everything you can at it that's
the nature of this bill really I mean I
don't think this is going to solve the
plastic pollution problem
single-handedly but it's just another
way to attack the problem
yeah represent
Duty yes thank you um so I have this
aggravation in my life okay where I buy
a lot of bird seed from the natural
Farmers Exchange and all of them have a
number five recyclable on them so the
big the big bags so I went to recycle
them of course don't take those in NASA
so I called the company and said great
you've got this recycling label on it
where do I recycle it so they said oh
well in New Hampshire you go to gtown
because the Goffstown transfer station
will take them so I call the gtown
transfer station and they say we don't
have have absolutely no idea what you're
talking about so I went back to customer
service and I said okay there's no place
that I can recycle them why do you tell
me that I can recycle them and of course
you know the answer answer no dead
silence okay I never got a response from
them so I'm saving all my bags and I'm
going to put them in a box and I'm going
to mail them back to the company because
that really really makes me quite upset
but the question is is would this bill
or do we have a way of handling that
because in my opinion that's pretty
deliberate that that that's that's
pretty deliberate fra fraud so would
this bill um
enhance my ability to report them to the
Attorney General's office and maybe have
them do something about it I would think
so uh representative Duty I mean uh this
bill would strengthen your case uh
because you know from the get-go they
have a false label on their product that
tells you that it's recyclable and you
went through all these hoops I mean
obviously their customer service is in
line with that fraudulent you know
misleading claim and they're they're
just repeating that but
yeah I mean this would enable you in
statute to say Hey you know this is
false advertising and we should be doing
something about
it any further questions I do yes
ma'am I guess my question to you then
would
be if an item like was just recently
described wasn't recoverable wasn't Rec
capturable and technically then not
recyclable by
default should not be something else in
place like an epr entity that would
encourage manufacturers to ensure that
the products are in some way on the back
end recoverable recyclable and not
landfill yeah I mean we know we have the
represent sorry to interrupt you but I
mean there is the hierarchy right reduce
reuse recycle um this bill is aimed at
uh reducing the use so is epr uh
unfortunately I heard that bill went
down I don't know if who was in this
committee this morning but um so that
that's no longer an option I mean would
I be in favor of this over epr no
obviously not epr is is a very
comprehensive uh set of uh you know
standards for the for industry to
rethink their their entire packaging and
the entire way they they do business but
um this is a little bit more focused
it's just saying hey you know we have
laws that protect consumers against
proel and advertising this is clearly a
case that is misleading and fraudulent
and will New Hampshire choose to do
something about it I don't know maybe
they will maybe maybe the Attorney
General will just you know just s sit on
it until people enough people complain
maybe they'll join with other states and
take a you know um a case against some
company to as a as
a as an example I I don't know but I
just think that it's clear that we need
something in in statute that protects
people from fraudulent
Behavior
representative H Haskins thank you Mr
chair just one quick question do we have
products that have the chasing arrows
and no
numbers that's a good question I don't I
don't think I've ever seen that but I'm
I'm not going to answer that really I
don't doesn't that mean that the
consumer needs to be following the
number rather than the chasing
arrows well I mean I think the whole
system is so complicated yeah I mean
theoretically maybe that's what the
consumer ought to be obviously yeah the
numbers are as important as the as the
chasing arrow symbol but do consumers
understand all those different
distinctions I don't know thank you and
representative Murray uh thank you Mr
chair and just to clarify I do want to
um just make one mention while we're
here we we do have a commitment from
this committee to further through an ad
hoc committee to address epr so I just
wanted to make sure that you were aware
of that thank thank you represent
yes all right representative thank you
so much for your testimony and
introducing the bill I'd like to call
Michael Nor from De uh Dees
please uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee um for the record my name
is Mike nor with the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental
Services um while this bill seems well
intentioned and while the department
certainly uh supports efforts to
increase recycling of plastics we do
oppose this bill because of uh the
resources that would be implied for
implementation um it would be
problematic from a resource standpoint
um at the heart of this bill uh it's
about regulating the consumer
Marketplace uh which is
in it's a area that Dees doesn't
currently have any resources devoted to
so in order to actually implement this
bill it would require probably pretty
significant uh boost of resources to our
to our to the work that we do um because
there's a a myriad of consumer products
that would be subject to this bill
probably thousands of different types
of products that have that recycling
symbol stamped on them um everything
from you know yogurt container ERS cups
and uh milk jugs water bottles uh things
that we can't even think of right now
there's just so many different things
I'm and it changes all the time and we
all go grocery shopping and we all see
the different packaging
um so I think just to to address one of
the comments that uh was brought up by
representative Kaplan in his uh
introduction to the bill why would Dees
need to um assess this product by
product because ultimately in order to
enforce this and imple implement this
effectively it would come down to
assessing individual products uh
because if a product is sold that has a
stamp on it and does not meet the
prescribed threshold for recycling uh
within the state the dees and with the
cooperation of the Attorney General's
office would have to uh pursue
enforcement um so it would be the
ultimately implementation would come
down to by product um the other question
that I think representative Kaplan had
was um why couldn't Dees just assess you
know how
many plastic bottles uh number one
plastic bottles versus number two
plastic bottles are recycled Statewide
currently I mean while it would be nice
to have this information currently Dees
doesn't get that information on a
specific material by material type um we
get information from Solid Waste
facilities like Town transfer stations
they submit their their annual facility
report to us uh and they report an
aggregate number for how much they've
recycled within the year that covers all
different types of materials so Plastics
paper cardboard metal uh you know metal
cans and things like
that so right now we don't have the
information to really even say like
what's the recycling rate for number one
pet or hdp or or
polypropylene
um so in order to implement this bill it
would take uh not only additional staff
at the department but probably also
hiring some sort of consulting firm to
conduct a market analysis on a periodic
basis uh to really be able to implement
this effectively uh because as I noted
the market changes periodically so if we
did a market analysis you know after
after this bill becomes
effective uh it's not to say that that
would
be up to date five years down the road
um so that market analysis would have to
be conducted on a periodic basis to
really make sure that products being
sold within the New Hampshire consumer
Marketplace are adhering to the
requirements it it would also be
necessary for Dees to collect more
information about what is the specific
recycling rate of those individual
products and
containers um so I I think while the
bill is certainly well intentioned and
it's at the heart of it it's really
trying to educate consumers about what
is isn't recyclable and create awareness
um through labeling efforts um it's just
not clear that the resources necessary
to implement it would be best use of of
limited State
resources um the the other thing I just
wanted to mention is
um there's a
effort within the the packaging industry
right now it's a voluntary labeling
effort called how to recycle many of you
if you're paying attention and trying to
figure out how to recycle items you may
have seen this it's a how the number two
recycle and then it'll often have um
little explanatory labels on there
saying you know if it's got a a
multi-layer pouch or something like that
says do not recycle dispose of in trash
versus the cardboard container that the
pouch comes in that is something you can
recycle so there is an effort uh on a
voluntary basis that consumer brands are
trying to to to participate in this how
to recycle effort to create more
consumer awareness around what is and
isn't recyclable in the products that
they they distribute um but I'll say you
know as somebody who's passionate about
Recycling and is you know obviously also
a consumer it is frustrating at times
when you buy products and it's not
something that you can readily recycle
uh there's definitely a lot of
complicating factors in this area so
with that I'm happy to take any
questions I just wanted to make a
statement for the record because um it
happens a lot in this committee this
letter it's it's a question time okay
statements are made in uh
deliberation representative
BBY yeah so um i' have a question about
um so if the numbers were removed from
the packages wouldn't that make it even
harder to track what was how much of
what was being recycled
um that's probably true uh I think
especially for the for the from the
consumer standpoint it would create more
confusion around what to do with the
item because if there's
no number like resin code on it uh it
might create a little bit of difficulty
in knowing exactly what to do with it
whether it is recyclable or not at least
the number code at least gives you some
pointers to like a a frame of
reference um yeah so I think it could
potentially be problematic because
Plastics can look alike even if they are
different actual resins like the
chemistry is different but they can look
similar you can have a clear uh number
number one pet but you can also have a
clear uh polystyrene number six um so
there's there's definit definite
potential for there to be contamination
if if people are mixing the same kinds
of resins together to be recycled sorry
different
resence and represent Penza for a
question so do you realize that the
commissioner um is appointed by the
executive branch and that the agency is
not allowed to take positions on
anything uh I'm aware that the
commissioner is appointed by by the
executive branch yes
followup so for a
followup so this whole letter that's put
in is is great giving us information but
did you realize that you can't say
oppose or or that you support a bill
because of that because it's from an
agency that's a post that's positioned
by the executive branch that that let's
discuss this afterwards that this letter
is from my knowledge it's it's a
authorized letter to send in and let's
discuss that words it says it right
there in the first paragraph We oppose
the bill I'm just I understand and I
also believe that having read this
letter for four and a half seconds that
it is an authorized letter to put
in so we can discuss it
afterwards and representative Murray um
thank you uh Mr chair for taking my
question thank you uh Mr nort for also
taking my question in addition to the uh
numbers inside the chasing arrows logo I
also wonder what the implications might
be and if you have any insight on what
the implications might be to the toter
that go out to the curb that have the
chasing arrows or any of those other
types of things could that potentially
further confuse the
efforts uh yeah um thank you represent
Murray that that's that's a good point
there's there's a large number of
plastic items that do have the
recycling chasing arrow symbol um mostly
consumer products that are you know kind
of quote single use and then intended to
be disposed of or recycled after use but
then there's a lot of durable goods like
you mentioned like toter um uh Furniture
car parts uh there's a a large uh the
case on this microphone or on your
computer at home um there's there's a
lot of plastic that is used in the
products that we buy and not all of them
have chasing arrows um I believe it was
representative Kaplan that mentioned 5%
of plastics is
recycled worldwide the plas of the
Plastics that we produce and put into
the marketplace only 5% is
recycled that statistic is kind of
changed over time it used to be 9% now
they're saying
5% um one thing to keep in mind with
that statistic is that it's often used
in a misleading manner it's often used
to conflate those consumer goods that
are intended to be
recycled with all plastic items
including durable goods that are not
intended they're intended to have a
longer life span um but those items were
produced never thinking that they were
going to enter in the consumer recycling
stream um so it's it can be a little
problematic to say that F only 5% of
recyclables are sorry only 5% of
plastics are recycled because it doesn't
that that's looking at the whole
pie really
the and people think that that means
that the F you know only 5% of the
Plastics I put in my recycling bin get
recycled the fact of the matter is most
of the Plastics that you put in your
recycling bin get recycled because
probably 60 to 70% of the plastic stream
is number ones and
twos by weight if you're just looking at
you know the weight the mass of plastic
in the in the recycling stream and the
consumer products that we buy uh number
five is also probably you know good
five% or so uh and then all the others
you know threes fours five sixes and
sevens are a relatively small percentage
and those are the Plastics that don't
they don't really have a market um so
it's it's just important I'm just saying
just for for the committee's awareness
that of the Plastics that we actually
put into a recycling stream the vast
majority do get
recycled it's just the larger problem is
that there's so much plastic out there
that when you look at that again the
whole whole piie really we're only
recycling a small percentage of the
total amount of plastics that we produce
sorry represent muray that was kind of a
a tangent but I hope that helped address
your question appropriate thank you all
right any other
questions all right sir thank you so
much for your
testimony and what's
that are there any other uh
anyone else that would like to testify
this I do not have a pin card
on okay and if I can get the blue sheet
that would be
awesome next and there are four opposed
to the bill on the on the pink
sheet on the blue sheet pink blue and
then uh online there are 24 supporting
and four
opposed and this concludes the hearing
on HP
1376 thank
you
okay so
16 all
right and you closed out uh the hearing
I did all right good enough okay thank
you I'm
back here comes trouble all right um I'm
going to open up the hearing on HB
1681 which is relative to the sale of
products labeled as biodegradable or
compostable and here today to introduce
this bill to us is representative
parshall welcome to environment
agriculture this afternoon and I thank
all of you for your interest in this and
I'm going to pass out uh proposed
amendment first thing I'll come back and
address
that
all
right some point we're G have to address
all these people that are on their
people
um all
right
this first of all I'd like to know for
committee members do you all have a copy
of the bill
1681 no okay I think we we may have a
pile of them over
there hold on one
second
do we have
enough this is the amended
[Music]
one so we have we have the bill being
handed out the original Bill and also a
copy of the amended
Bill a proposed amendment proposed
amended Bill yes proposed
amendment so
um thank you for your
patience um so representative parall why
don't you explain to us what the bill is
and what your amendment is yes I'll say
first that the amendment pretty much
replaces all of the language in the bill
uh the spirit of the language remains
however uh the amendment brings this
more in line with What legislation has
been passed in other states and
effectively has been divorced in other
states it's a more successful document I
hope because of
that
now mostly the original bill and the
amendment it's a language Bill we uh use
words like biodegradable and Co and
compostable and even recycling they all
get lumped in together
and when we say compostable we are
talking about a particular product that
we expect to break down under certain
circumstances in a reasonable amount of
time uh as you know plastic is not in
that category but when we go into uh a
restaurant and then say that they're uh
their service wear is compostable
anybody can make that claim what this
bill does that actually said say if
you're going to make that claim how are
you going to back it
up uh it restricts that language to
uh a certification
process which
uh and I I will say one of the people
who have helped me write the Bell was
that the uh oh my goodness BPI
Laboratories as happened to be down in
the cafeteria earlier I got my BPI cup I
know if I toss this into our compostable
materials here it will get it will break
down under reasonable
circumstances um and I think it's
important for consumers to know that to
be able to look for the label to know
what is compostable and to be able to
make those choices when they make their
purchases um why is this important we
just had some wonderful Landmark
legislation last year addressing large
manufacturers of large compostable was
waste stream and I would just like to
see that waist stream remain pure from
uh uh non-compostable materials and this
bill will do as much um it doesn't ban
the use of or sale or distribution of
plastic materials it doesn't ban the use
of language such as recycling but it
does reserve the word compostable and
biodegradable to a certifiable
process and
uh and while it's something which we
could enforce on a federal level I think
enforcing on a state level does make a
lot more sense we have the feet on the
ground here within the state of New
Hampshire to enforce this kind of of
legislation
um and
uh and last there's a educational aspect
of the bill as I said I like the BPI
label on this there are other
Laboratories as well but there's a
certain assurance that we get that when
we're buying a product produ that we
expected to act act a certain way so
we've become the process of requiring
our large producers to compost now we
need to help them out to ensure their
compostible materials free remains free
from contaminants and this law hopefully
does as much yes may I open myself up to
questions representative
Murray thank you madam chair I have a
series of so if I ask okay thank you may
ask questions and any necessary followup
thank you I just wanted to be clear um
it seems that there are some
strikethroughs On Your sponsorship so I
just wanted to make sure that we're all
operating on the same premise can you
speak to that
oh um I was
not I would wager that these people
would still be happy to sponsor I my
understanding is that when you submit a
bill to be amended all sponsorship is
stripped from it I see okay so I I I
just took the liberty of doing that no I
don't think anybody has deserted me
person
so just one moment is this this
amendment actually gone through OS it
has not because I know you're doing a
work study next week on this and I just
want to make sure that it's as
comprehensive to answer your questions
as possible and so I think that it would
be better if we rather than submit
Amendment after Amendment if we could th
address it all with them once in case we
find other things that need gotcha
repair whatever gotcha okay go ahead and
represent Murray I'm sorry to have
interrupted no no that's okay um and
then my other question would be
um does I don't see it anywhere but it
may exist in these other sort of DS uh
d640 the numbers excuse meor there's no
numbers on 339 colon 80 um is there
anything that specifically talks about
contaminants such as pasas or potential
other ingredients in quote compostable
materials um no there is not but my
understanding is that
certain certain things like uh past and
it's aligned forever chemicals would
prohibit uh item from being labeled as
certified as compostable to begin with
according to their lab according to
their Labs so that would be you know
although the bill doesn't specifically
and that RSA does not specifically
mention anything about past for for or
forever chemicals the certification
process to get the compostable uh stamp
on the
serviceware um would preclude any forber
chemicals being included in the lining
or like
okay sorry representative Bixby yeah so
um I think this might this followup
might clarify um ref Murray's question a
little bit so uh you you cite ASM
standards d64 6400
d6868 and D
8410 and my guess is that you haven't
memorized exactly what those those
standards um require but um K you say
roughly if those standards are something
that the um the American Society for
testing and materials uh have determined
to uh compost uh to a um a clean to a
clean compost do a six-month breakdown
with no plastic or microplastic residue
I believe that's how it is and it's and
it's not that's the American on it's
this is pretty much a world standard
yeah American Standards are similar to
the world ones but oh you're absolutely
correct I have not memorize these I was
just saying a the ASM because that's
what you cited in the bill and that's
the standard that you're saying we
should use and I appro I approve of
you're putting that in rather than the
specific lab that would the BPI that you
have in in the original bill that's was
one of the changes that actually BPI
suggested for the bill yeah
so representative dsy oh I'm sorry did
were you finished I move on and okay
representative Duty thank you uh
representative parel I'm a little um
confused about the second paragraph
under uh section
339 so are you saying uh and the reason
I'm asking this is because I remember
getting uh something in plastic and it
either had the word biodegradable or
compostable on it so I put it in my
compost heap and I haven't found it
lately I think it took a year but I
haven't found it lately so I think it
degraded but so are you saying here that
no plastic um can be labeled
biodegradable uh because no plastic it
really degrades is that what this is all
about uh I'm a little confused yes if
we're adding plastic to our composting
material that plastic may break down
into microplastic but it will never
actually degrade to the point of making
that soil making that compost a
commercial
product representative Co
Kul thank you madam chair and thanks for
uh building my question here so it says
there is a misdemeanor penalty in this
bill I'm curious who's going to jail is
it the producer or the retailer of the
falsely labeled
biodegradable
container who's going to get in trouble
here for I would suggest that the person
that would get in trouble would be the
person making the claim I should also
add thank you for asking me about that I
I I would also like to add that that's
pretty much stock language under all the
penalties in this 80
so
um uh sub chapters of that
339 uh RSA it's all they always refer to
a guilty of a violation if a natural
person so it's that's stock language
what the actual penalty they would
actually do I'll be frank with you I
really don't know what the actual
misdemeanor penalty would be but uh I
would assume it' be the person that
would be making that claim if it's not
uh
certifiable so I hope that ansers your
question i' just like to point out that
um seeing as this is not a document that
has been vetted by the office of
legislated services sort of huh that's
very true yes uh so that this is just
sort of
your um stab at
initial thoughts of how the underlying
bill could be changed could be should be
and um so the actual legal language that
they would use is not something that's
before us I think I'm understanding it
better that it's this it's the penalty
that's in this chapter 339 I think I'm
getting it more now representative
ger thank you madam chair thank you
representative parshall for taking my my
question uh and it's already kind of
answered to an extent but my question
was going to be isn't the language that
you're suggesting already present in RSA
339 both with regard to the Penalty
which is under a misdemeanor but also
with regard to for example
33961 which has to do with false
representation uh which is under this
same chapter so in isn't this
effectively a a kind of a a a new
iteration of something that already
exists within that RSA with the
accompanying language yes I would I
would agree with that because it is
false representation but this is a very
specific example of that type of false
representation and other than that yes
it is stock language uh from not only
our own RSA but this Al also you know I
mean I've used model legislation in the
past to draft legislation this is pretty
much I would say almost rtim what has
worked in five other states in including
Maryland Minnesota Colorado California
and Washington all have similar state
laws that employ this very similar
language may I followup followup yeah
thank you uh and and so in addition to
all of the other states wouldn't it be
fair to say that this is a reflection of
a commitment based on the idea of false
representation that this legislature has
already
endorsed yes I think it'd be a fair char
thank you representative
Duty uh so representative parel um right
now we have um we have no laws regarding
um labeling something biodegradable or
compostable or do we so this bill came
about because there were um issues with
people labeling things biodegradable but
they actually weren't uh and I'll just
say one other thing because you know I'm
I'm come from the world of uh ISO
standards and ik standards and um you
know so a lot of times you'd have a seal
you know and it would be ISO certified
or something like that so this bill is
coming about because that doesn't exist
in New Hampshire that does not exist in
New Hampshire it exists worldwide exists
in those five states that I previously
mentioned and it does not exist on the
federal level um although the
certification is something that people
seek out obviously um the legislation
came about I will tell you I was sitting
down with a friend of mine whose
business it is uh is to uh gather
compost in Kean New Hampshire I believe
our represent shman uses his services
like they like you put your recycling
out your trash out you put your compost
out this young gentleman in his business
come by and pick up the compost and they
see that it goes to a high temperature
um recycling Center which is really
built perfectly for to break down these
kind of materials and
um and it came up that that was one of
the problems that he was facing was that
he's not getting sometimes he gets less
than clean compostable material because
there is an educational element that is
somewhat lacking and there's a
legislative element that would back up
that educational element so that's kind
of the Genesis of this whole situation
there if that helps your
thinking okay represent yeah thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my question could you just
clarify for me um does this impact me
buying compostable cups at the store or
does it also include a restaurant that
is selling you food in a compostable cup
it does not impact any of that if you
want to buy your
non-recyclable plastic uh champagne
glass from the store this will not
affect that um but if that package
contains a claim that it is compostable
or
biodegradable then there will be an
effect on that this does not Outlaw any
particular kind of service wear okay
follow I'd like to be very clear on that
actually so thank you for asking
representative NAB um so if I go to a
Mexican restaurant and it says or even
the works across the street like they
have a compostable all our cups are
compostable you put it in the compost
section is that are they being targeted
or is it somebody that rep that sells
something that's packaged as
biodegradable or
compostable I
would hate to think that this is
targeting anybody per se I would like to
think it's Pi a different word but do do
you understand what I'm getting at I do
understand what you're saying at but um
no it it's this is I see a law like this
is prevent the type of green washing
that we sometimes witness where you know
hooray for our side we're an
environmental company and we do things
this way and that way it's just
protecting the consumer and making the
consumer aware that certain language you
know that words matter and certain words
do matter and I do believe the works
everything product that they sell is
compostable does contain the same BPI
label it's it's more common I think
people really know so there's it would
not be a big hurdle to educate people in
this area but uh and and and I don't
have a better word than a Target but but
but I just had to make clear yeah I
don't it's okay representative Bixby so
I I think perhaps what uh we're trying
to get at here is
uh where the point of enforcement is and
it sounds like the point of enforcement
is not the consumer nor is it the
retailer but rather the company that is
packaging and making packaging and
labeling something as compostable so it
would be the producer of that that puts
on a label that says compostable that
would have to B be able to back it up is
that correct I think it' be hard to hold
uh the works as an example I what I Free
Press here liable when they buy a
product that claims to be compostable
they find that it isn't but if they see
their product is claiming to be
composable and they and they see that it
does not have that code they may have
the wherewithal to
say uh they want to see this on their
product if they're going to make that
claim uh and I think it would be in
their preview to uh ask any of these
larger manufacturers to either have
their products certified or not make
that claim okay follow up follow up okay
so but what I what I'm getting at is
that if there's going to be an
enforcement action uh using the you know
using the enforceability that is in that
chapter yes then uh the Attorney General
is going to go after the company that
stamps the compostable label on it that
is not backed up by third party testing
as opposed to going after any retailer
that has anything to do with it I would
hope so I I think that's where the uh
responsibility should lie and I would
hope that would be the case okay thank
you representive Duty um yes thank you
madam chair uh yeah the only thing if
you're looking for for feedback that I
would say is that I think for consumers
it would be helpful if it says
biodegradable uh says something like
meets um ASM standards you know or
certified by something like that because
I think you know that uh one I think you
know I would say it would be more
enforcable because they they've made the
claim that they're certified and they
have it on their label and I think from
a consumer's perspective it just adds um
verification and validity you know so I
would like to to see maybe that added to
your Amendment some some kind of
enhanced labeling yes I really not bring
this as a may I you may okay I did I did
not bring this as a prop I I I guarantee
it but I'm looking at it right now
underneath my little BPI I know I'm not
asking you to try to see this but it
says cert certifiable number it has the
number of how it was certified so
perhaps that would be some very good May
that perhaps would be one change with me
you want to make on here you know or at
least call awareness
to now representative parall and we had
a bill last year year before I don't
remember anymore they just Mel into one
another um having to do with um
flushable wipes that claim to be
flushable but they're
not and that's kind of the same seems to
me to be the same kind of issue where
you have the producer of the product
making a claim on their labor
that is not
true
um
how how I mean I don't I'm not
sure how that gets enforced with this I
mean we we couldn't really enforce
something like that on the other Pro on
the flushable
products without having some sort of
federal
labeling um correction being
made so I'm kind of don't
know how this fits in with
that I wish I could had an answer for
I'll be very honest with you I wish I
could I'm not familiar with the eventual
outcome of the flushable wipes but I see
that as another case of you know we're
talking about greenwashing here making a
claim on a product that's not actually
there
um I would not not
expect a ton
of lawsuits around this particular issue
I would really be surprised if there
were I think most consumers now are be
are educating themselves become very
aware of the problems of compostability
and I think this would be an assurance
to them that the product has has indeed
met a few standards so I see that
benefit coming from this um I think you
probably have to find somebody that was
probably doing something very egregious
in order to uh actually pull in any kind
of enforcement standards I'm not saying
it wouldn't happen but I'm saying
that I think you'd really have to I mean
I think
most 80% of the people who are producing
these things I think have they want to
do the right thing they're not doing it
for the sake of green washing they want
to make sure their product is
compostable and they're going to easily
comply it's the you know 5 to 20% that
we're going to have problems with and I
really think that if we can educate the
retail outlets such as the works is to
our need to have this uh
certification I think organizations like
that be very quick to jump on board and
say no we don't want your compostable
product not unless you can get a
certified compostable I believe but
again that's I will be quick to say it's
speculation I really can't say for
certain any other questions from the
committee seeing
none I invite Michael Nork from NHD yes
to come up and speak on this
bill sorry I forgot one thing I should
mention by the way go right ahead and
now that you mentioned thank you so much
um I did refer to this this bill
originally was uh slated for another
section of the law Michael knor and his
uh Dees were very helpful in suggesting
that we move it to another place within
the law where it may be more clearly
enforceable I believe but I believe he
will speak to that that is one other
change that is made in this amendment I
just want to be very clear on that yeah
I noticed that this um sort of moves it
into Commerce territory yeah and we're
not in this committee not really
um fluent in Commerce law so
um kind of a little um concerned about
that aspect of this amendment but um in
any case thank you for br we sooner I
apologize but we've got it now
yeah representive partial we need you to
fill out a pink slip
please
uh thank you madam chair and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Michael norc with New Hampshire
Department of Environmental
Services uh the written testimony that
I'm handing out now was written before
we became aware that representative
partial was contemplating this amendment
that he previously handed out to the
committee um just to speak to that
briefly uh when Dees saw the original
draft of this bill we noted that it
was placed in RSA 149 M27 which is a
section of the statute that deals with
items disposed from items banned from
disposal in landfills or incinerators in
New Hampshire that section of the
statute is all about items banned from
disposal but the subject matter of the
bill was about distribution of products
in the in the marketplace so we noted
that that seemed to be inconsistent with
that section of the stat statute which
is why we communicated to representative
parall that it seems like this is more a
Commerce related bill so his Amendment
uh doesn't necessarily change the
content of the bill it just changes its
location and statute to be more in line
with what the subject matter of the bill
actually is um and so having said that
the again the letter that I passed
around noted that Dees uh opposed this
bill um but we had written that before
we were aware that this this uh
amendment was in the works um if this
amendment were to be introduced after
after having briefly re reviewed it it
looks like it would address those
concerns that we had about its placement
in statute about uh imposing
responsibilities on Dees to enforce um
so having said that I think um the
amendment would address the concerns
that the department originally
had um I just want to note very very
generally that labeling of compostable
products uh is something that has
created a lot of confusion in the
marketplace over the years um marketers
tend to use language very freely like
biodegradable or uh oxodegradable
or uh you know uh different type types
of terminology to imply that something
will break
down
uh the
the having a standard for what is
actually certified as composable would
help to reduce that consumer confusion
um it
would uh provide a you know a standard
that people would be able to point to to
say no we want it to be actually
certified as compostable so that we can
be assured that if it goes to a facility
that can take it that it would break
down
um I think just to to I was making notes
when the the committee was asking
questions earlier somebody I forgot who
asked about the language in the I'm not
sure are we rep um chair Ain are we able
to talk about the the language in the
the proposed amendment or should we
stick to the language of the actual bill
is introduced well I guess we've kind of
already um introduced the possibility of
an amendment being um offered and
presented to OS for some final um
wording so I just the idea of the
proposed amendment I think is probably
okay because we've already been talking
about making that
change um so sure thank you I just want
to clarify that's if that's acceptable
because I I believe somebody had raised
a question about the language saying no
plastic product may be labeled with the
term biodegradable degradable
decomposable oxodegradable or similar
form of those terms I believe that Lang
language is intended to address
situations where somebody markets an
item as quote
degradable but really that there's no
there's no standard to back that up I
think what
this bill would the intention here is to
make sure that something is labeled as
certified compostable and that's the
language that would be used either it
meets that standard or it doesn't and
they can't use other language that could
create confusion among consumers things
like biodegradable um because that is
current practice in the marketplace
there are products I was looking at um
actually of all things garbage bags um
that say
biodegradable uh and I was very confused
by that because it it's going to go to a
landfill where things don't really
biodegrade anyway um so you know there's
there's a lot of different marketing
ploes out there and so having a standard
for something that is actually certified
as compostable provided is given the the
proper conditions for composting um I
think you know that that would help uh
reduce consumer
confusion um and the the standards the
ASM standards d6400 d6868 and
8410 um those are standards used by uh
BPI which was previously uh mentioned by
representative parall um BPI the
biodegradable products Institute um they
are the industry leader on certifi like
providing third party certification for
uh products that are compostable um
they're kind of the gold standard uh and
they there was another question that one
of the committee members brought up
about pasas being the presence of pasas
BPI has it as part of their standard for
I can back up what represented parall
was saying BPI has part of their
standard uh that products that they
certify cannot have presence of Florine
greater than 100 parts per million
uh so they have a standard to try to
address intentional use of uh
fluorinated compounds like
P um so I guess I'll leave it at that if
there's any questions from the
committee representative Murray thank
you madam chair again yes and thank you
uh Mr n for taking my questions one of
the things that I did have questions
around was between the difference
between quote
biodegradable and compostable and my
understanding is that they are different
things and if you could speak to that a
little bit sure thank you for the
question um yeah so compostable is
really more specific than biodegradable
or degradable um because a lot of
products and
materials can degrade over time because
of exposure to UV or exposure to the
elements um there there is some
decomposition that can happen um where
products break down especially with
plastics where they break down but they
tend to break down
into pieces like smaller pieces of
plastic um so the term composable is
more specific it really refers to
something that will break down in a
composting environment to the to the
point where there's no
recognizable fragments or pieces of that
product left after a certain period of
time after being exposed to composting
uh
conditions um this actually just uh
reminded me that uh there was some
comment earlier about Plastics
specifically and whether they could be
certified as compostable the fact of the
matter is yes that there are Plastics
that can be certified as compostable and
that will actually break down uh through
thermophilic
composting um and those Plastics are
known as polylactic acid or pla um so
there are like you'll see you know I
think even the works might have cups
that are like a clear plastic but they
are certified compostable so those items
if they were sent to a compos posting
facility would break down even though
they're plastic it's just a certain type
of plastic it's actually pla I just
recalling from the previous uh hearing
talking about Plastics recycling pla is
actually one of the number
sevens follow up yeah thank you madam
chair and to that end I guess um that
was part of the the question that I did
have was that I did notice that there
was like an ASM standard that talked
about just biodegration of plastics and
that's def
5338 and so I didn't see that listed in
here and I was just curious as to
whether or not there were other ASM
standards that may fall in this area
that are not yet in this mixture here
that's a good question I am by no means
an expert on all of the ASM standards
that exist there are innumerable
different standards I believe that d6400
is a general decomposition of packaging
and that D68 68 and 8410 if I recall
correctly are targeted at items made of
plastic so I think and I believe
representative parall said that this
language was recommended by BPI to try
to cover those kinds of potential
scenarios where the product may be made
out of plastic or maybe made out of
other materials um so I believe that
this is probably comprehensive there may
be other standards out there but I don't
think that BPI or other certification
organizations necessarily
use I'm sorry I I don't remember the
standard that you cited but
um
okay I'll uh I can look that one up if
you'd like and I can get back to you
about that thank
you I have a question first um and then
you so my question is um if we were to
consider drafting an amendment for the
underlying bill will similar to the
proposed ideas in what we see as an
quote unquote an
amendment do you think it would be
helpful useful to actually um put in
definitions for each one of the things
that we're talking about such as
biodegradable degradable
decomposable oxy
degradable do you think we should have
um
specific definitions for those
terms
um given the way this is written
currently I think
it's prohibiting use of that terminology
I don't know that it would be helpful to
have a definition and because the the
intent here is to say that marketers of
these products shouldn't be using that
terminology they should be using uh some
sort sort of label that gives uh
authority of a certifying like a third
party certifying organization so I'm not
sure that it would be in my view helpful
to have definitions of those terms if
those terms are not intended to be used
by by the the marketing companies I
don't know if that
helps
yeah but you know my point is okay so
this is saying that Plastic Products can
never fall into those
categories apparently that's they can't
be labeled using that terminology right
right so since they can't fall into
those categories they can't be labeled
as such but I think just for intent for
for the law
itself um it might be worthwhile
to have a definition of what those terms
mean so that we do know that Plastics
don't fall under those
terminologies that's the committee's
prerogative obviously um I I don't have
a strong opinion one way or the other I
was just expressing my offthe cuff okay
kind of in my impression that it
probably wouldn't be necessary but it's
obviously your prerogative
representative Bixby yeah so I was
wondering um if we are if we do a work
session on this uh in order to amend it
uh would it be possible for you to be a
available that uh at that point uh to us
to um give us further advice so that we
don't like fall down any un unseen pits
or anything uh absolutely we'd be happy
to to coordinate with a a a subcommittee
or the committee as a whole great thank
you representative
Katon thank you madam chair just I lost
you I think um under the amendment it
said no no plastic product may be
labeled but then you talked about pla
that were in fact
compostable and so are there exceptions
to this paragraph that we should include
or I mean this is not accurate
then to to your statement I I think you
rais a a good point representative Katon
that it's confusing
um the I think the way to think about
this is if a product is going to be
marketed for with the intent that it
should break down for composting that it
should be labeled in a manner that says
it's certified for composting not using
other terminology like biodegradable or
so the fact of the matter is there are
Plastics that can be
composted and that that could meet
the uh certification of a third party
for
composting um trying to think of a
better way to explain this B basically
there are Plastics that can be composted
and then there are Plastics that cannot
be composted but that may be currently
in the
marketplace uh they they may be marketed
as biodegradable or using some other
vague terminology that makes it sound
like they are um I think the intent here
is to
really make sure that the labeling is
consistent and that there is a standard
and that standard is set by a third
party that has has authority to to to
verify that these products are able to
to be composted okay thank you thank
you representative compto thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um so we're talking about
compostable Plastics or
plas do they contain
pafs I don't know for certain but I know
that uh those items that are certified
by BP
Pi are because of their their rigorous
system for
certification uh they make sure that the
manufacturers are not intentionally
adding P or other fluorinated compounds
to the products so I can't say that
across the board that all pla doesn't
contain past but I know that there are
systems in place for the certification
of those
products
to not to to limit the the possibility
that that could happen there could be
products out there that are not
certified um that may contain
P any other
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for for your expertise in this field
and uh I do not have any other pink
cards for this particular Bill if
there's anybody else who wishes to speak
272 okay so that um we do have the the
blue sheet which is um one person
against this
bill and we had I'm sorry on that was on
272 and zero 27 two and Zer four or
against four 27
274 two two against zero zero okay do
have one question I'm sorry sure I just
saw on the blue sheet um can I see the
blue sheet real quick oh that was uh Mr
norc yeah Mr nor on on the blue sheet
you have
opposed but in your testimony you said
that you would be for the amendment and
so the blue sheet was for the bill not
the amendment but just to be clear
you're for the amendment the bill is
amended with this proposed
amendment uh correct that again I I
filled out the the no no I I understand
I just want to make sure that I had that
correct thank you thank you thank you
all right with that I'm going to close
out the hearing on hb1
1681 we have some time between uh that
and the next bill which is to be heard
at 3:30 so let's take a little bit of a
break go stretch your
legs and we'll see you at
3:30
excuse
thank
you environment and agriculture members
please take your seats we're about to
begin our next hearing we're already two
minutes
late
sure
okay I'm G to open up the hearing for HB
1504 relative to architectural paint
recycling and here to introduce the bill
is our favorite representative parall
should I just put a 10 up here maybe uh
move in thank you thank you again
members of the committee
um this is a bill that came about before
the epr for packing bill which you exed
earlier today um was even in a draft
form
and I
uh and I think it is something which is
long overdue for New Hampshire I think
that I go to my local transfer station
and there is no clear mandate on how
from One Transport station to the next
on how to deal with this problem uh is
this a
solution
um I think that it has worked
effectively in other
states um
and uh you know other than that I mean
perhaps you know there there are a lot
of unknowns in this bill how much will
it cost it's a that's a you know I mean
I think the financial note does a very
good job of addressing those areas
[Music]
um perhaps we need twofold legislation
this under some other aspect aspect
which does include such things as
producer responsibility or organizations
the other Bill did that this bill has no
provision for that it does ask for the
uh um producers of M these materials
step forward and I always think that's a
very essential part of all of this I
think we do need to have the people are
helping to create our waste need to be
more responsible and I think this bill
does a good deal on that but
um I am sensitive to some of the bills
deficits as well is what I'm trying to
say and uh and with that I'll I I hate
to cut it short because I just to open
up to questions
any um any questions from the committee
representative NAB I just have a very
basic question thank you what is
architectural
paint it's the technical term okay for
the paint that that I just used last
week to paint my living room it's you
know that's basically what you buy off
the shelf in your local paint store so
not paint not l latex paint other latex
oil if you you know people still it's
you know all right thank you
whatever any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
represent big just there you go um okay
so I didn't do all of my homework so
could you just give a kind of brief
description of how this would work um
well there's a stewardship program like
with our the other build we've been
looking at
odium um sorry and
um and and there's a stewardship program
attached to it uh the stewardship
program will have manufacturers on board
of that stewardship program they'll need
to come up with endol life uh management
process including the collection
Transportation possible Recycling and
procing of all this post consumer paint
uh contact information for those people
who are responsible
and um just goals for
reducing postc consumer paint waste a
list of very valuable a list of uh
collection sites right now
of and Kean they were very
very my my home county Keen was very
specific as to how we were supposed to
deal with this type of thing and
currently in my currently small town we
just dump a bunch of sand in it and tall
into the
dumpster so there's a there's a variant
on how these uh you know and this
removes a lot of that variance and I
think that would be a value in of
itself representative dsy uh thank you
madam chairperson did you know I'm
supposed to call you chairperson madam
chairperson yeah so so I'll try to start
doing that no fine you could call me
Madam chairman um I I just want to say I
believe uh we have a person that's going
to testify um that has um uh experience
in uh seeing uh seeing this process work
out at a um conference that he went to
so perhaps that might be the next step
you know that we could move this along
and I I also understand there's a lot in
here that puts responsibility on to Dees
so if I hear you correctly uh
representative um this probably should
go to uh an interim study so that we can
work with various stakeholders to work
out the details is that correct yes I'm
already very sensitive the DS needs for
Staffing and INF fancing and I think
that may have came out and perhaps I may
have damaged my testimony by admitting
as much but yeah I I think maybe I would
be happily uh suspend the floor to give
the floor to there off thank you thank
you anyone anyone else any other
comments I know
um thank you representative paral
appreciate it I had asked our committee
researcher to provide us with a document
um giving us some information about some
of the past uh legislation that was
offered for architectural paint
recycling and she had prepared that sent
a copy to all of us so you might want to
take a look and see what uh what had
been proposed in the past what were some
of the issues with it um and I think
it's an interesting uh document that was
put together the
architect I I you didn't get it oh okay
yeah well send it along I thought you
had sent it to the rest of the committee
not just me no all right we're all good
okay um and in any case I'd like to call
up the honorable Tim
Josephson good afternoon and welcome to
environment and agriculture good
afternoon thank you very much uh I
served in this house from 2017 to 2021s
and I recognize some of you familiar
faces yeah thank you so now I come I now
I come here in my capacity I work for
the Upper Valley Lake Sunapee Regional
Planning Commission I'm here to neither
testify in favor nor against this bill
but just to provide some background
information as to I've seen with
architectural paint recycling um this
past September I was able to go to a
conference well let me backtrack here so
at the regional Planning Commission one
of the things that I do is I run our
household hazardous waste collection
program uh we hold five events a year in
the Upper Valley in Lake Sunapee area uh
we take all of your chemicals your
oilbased paints your batteries all your
random stuff that you can't throw in the
landfill we'll take it and we work with
the hauler to uh dispose of it
responsibly one of the most common
requests we get is what do I do with
latex paint uh and right now we tell
them throw some kitty litter in it dry
it out and toss it in the trash not only
is that I mean let alone the
environmental impact of that is wasteful
it's really wasteful especially when you
have you know that much paint left at
the bottom of your can uh this past
September I was able to go to the North
American Hazard North American hazardous
materials management Association
conference in uh Tempe Arizona and we
were able to tour some facilities of
their uh Public Works facilities in
Tempe Gilbert and Mesa and they in
Arizona they have a very active paint
recycling program uh these cities uh run
it they run it themselves at the city
level um but it can be run in any manner
that you wish uh what they do is they
have they just accept paint latex paint
of all types and they recycle it and
it's very very simple in that they just
filter it out and mix it together and
they they come up with h three colors
they have white tan and gray because
when you mix everything together that's
what you end up getting um I can see I
saw in the you know in all three of
those cities they were able to use a lot
of that paint for um their own U
municipal buildings uh especially you
know in Arizona the tan comes in very
handy um but they were able to use it in
things like graffiti cover up they were
able to sell it at a very low price or
give it away in some cases to community
groups that uh either needed it for like
you know a Habitat for Humanity house or
something like that um so it went back
into the community um and so what I just
really wanted to share was and just kind
to make myself available for any
questions I could answer um was just how
Frugal this is It's it fits with our you
know our Yankee frugality here in New
Hampshire uh we don't like to waste
things you know I go to my transfer
station I see you know the the picket
pile and you can see what you can use
and stuff and I know some places have
you know maybe a little Shelf with some
latex paint you can get um but it's not
a widespread program and I think that
just makes sense for someone for New
Hampshire to participate in this um just
because of because of the uh efficacy of
it um the other yeah the that's that's
pretty much what I had uh to say I'm
happy to answer any questions about how
I can answer the best I can how these
pro programs work um in Most states it
is under a dollar for a charge for a
gallon of paint um which is it's not a
it's not a tax it's not a fee it's it's
the responsibility that you are paying
for the cleanup of the product um you
know and I think the highest one in the
nation is Vermont right now at a .92 and
I don't know if you looked at the price
of uh a gallon of paint lately I just
painted my one of my bathrooms recently
and I 55 bucks for a gallon of paint so
you know 94 cents on top of that is not
going to break my bank it's not going to
make me say I'm not going to buy that
paint um it's just a matter of fact it's
part of the responsibility I have in
buying the paint and making sure that I
clean it up at the end so um yeah that's
that's all I have and happy to answer
any questions I
can represent Murray thank you Madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um so I I'd love to hear a
little bit more about the the
program
and do you see there being a cost
associated with running I know you're
saying that the gallon of paint
themselves cost a dollar um but are
there any costs that you learned about
or saw that were born to a department uh
in the state for running the program not
necessarily only in oversight is that it
would be so so if there was any cost
associated with the direct oversight of
this program um but the state was not
collecting the paint the state was not
you know filtering it or things like
that um there was there was just an
oversight of making sure that the
companies were doing what they said they
were going to do um in many cases they
have a company that's contracted to kind
of run the program for the whole state
in many places it's a place called Paint
care um they work with places like you
know your Sherwin Williams or Benjamin
Moore that will they can take back all
your used paint and then they pack it up
and they ship it to paint care and paint
care takes care of it
and uh handles it out of you know
wherever they have their facility they
mix it and then they get it back to
whoever wants it
so okay and oh and and the the the sear
charge on top of you know the the the
gallon of paint or the quarter paint or
the five gallon bucket of paint whatever
you get that goes into the fund that
paint care uses to run the program
follow up followup M can you tell me
what that search charge generally was
that like I said that's the 95 cents
roughly like I said Vermont has the
highest at around
$192 is and they they are one of the
highest and in talking to them because
they are such a small state they are
just getting started with it and so they
um they didn't have the critical mass
obviously they have like half the
population of us so like they don't have
the critical mass of of people
representative
Bixby so um are the collection sites um
the uh like local transfer stations and
recycling centers or are that retail
stores or um or how does that work the
nice thing about this type of program is
you can set it up however you like um
some states some states have it where
you like I said you go to a Benin more
anywhere you buy the paint you can also
take it back um other states have it
where your local transfer station would
take it back um we run hazardous waste
collections so we would incorporate that
into our hHw collections in saying we
also take latex paint and then we would
work with our hauler to separate excuse
me separate that and get that to the to
the right
party represent Murray uh thank you so
you you seem to be describing a
structure at least with retail
establishments that we heard about
earlier today with regard to batteries
where you can take them to other uh
establishments potentially and return
batteries so it sounds similar with the
paints yeah yeah very very similar to
that it it all depends on how you want
to set it up you know if if um you know
the paint uh manufacturers associate you
know they didn't want to take it in at
their retail stores we could it could be
structured in the state to do it
differently and to take it at you know
local transfer stations or you know
hazardous waste collections or something
like that um that's another way you
could do
it so I have a question do you think um
a program like this could be
run just by an entrepreneur who's
interested in doing something like this
as opposed to a state-run program and
that they kind of could the the hang-up
ends up being is that there's no way to
fund the recycling of the paint because
it doesn't because you have to recoup
some costs up front from when people buy
paint um just taking in paint and then
selling it as recycled paint is not it
does not produce enough profit for them
to do that so that's why you so the
state has to say it's okay to charge a
search charge you know a fee on top of
the the sale of retail paint in order to
pay for that program so while it is
typically run by a third party a private
private business
um it does require some State
permissions I
see any other
questions thank you thank you so much
good to see
you I would like to call
um Michael Nor from
nhds and before you speak I just wanted
to let uh committee members know that um
New Hampshire Dees does have a
page uh regarding how to dispose of
paint uh they talk about water-based
paints and uh oil lead based
solvent-based paint stains and varnishes
uh they have fact sheets and all other
kind of
information and that is on the dees
website um news and media hash blog hash
paint so um with that I'll let Michael
North talk thank you thank you madam
chair thank you members of the committee
again Michael norc with New Hampshire
Department of Environmental
Services
um the is not taking a position on this
bill um and we you know we do understand
that a paint takeback program would
support goals in the solid waste
management plan by removing latex paint
from disposal as was described you know
folks drying it out and throwing it in
the track
uh and it would also decrease costs
incurred by municipalities that have
paint collection programs or um Regional
collection programs like the one that uh
with the Upper Valley like sunap
Regional Planning Commission um so with
those in mind uh you know we understand
that those would be positive outcomes of
a bill like this but we also have
concerns about uh the resources that
would be necessary to implement uh this
the bill as it's written um it's true
that this would be a stewardship uh or
an epr kind of program and that uh
organization such as paint care would
probably be the one implementing the
actual program but Dees would have
oversight uh and administrative
responsibilities as outlined in the bill
uh such as adopting administrative rules
reviewing and and approving plans to
establish the the takeback program uh
assuring compliance by manufacturers P
pursuing enforcement uh AAL valuating e
efficacy of the program reviewing annual
reports and also preparing and
submitting reports to the general court
so there's there is some administrative
duties that Dees would have to undertake
that we don't currently have resources
to do um this bill does not make an
appropriation for funding for or or
authorize the creation of new positions
um so that's just the concern that we
have is the the resources necessary um
with that being said if the committee is
looking to uh refer this to interim
study as as had been suggested um Dees
would welcome the opportunity to uh you
know participate in that process and
provide input happy to take any
questions from the committee thank you
represent Murray thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question in
the realm of thinking about um
possibilities of of things would the
department um or do you do you know if
the department would entertain the
possibility of there being maybe a pilot
of this to see if shorter term program
rather than some standing up something
permanently initially to get it going as
I don't know there's a lot that I heard
in the previous person's testimony that
I thought was um hopeful and it sounded
like to a large degree was self-funded
um so I'm I'm curious to know your
thoughts and
maybe on that yeah I that's an
interesting thought um I don't think you
know
without further context are specifics I
don't think I can really
comment in a definitive way on that but
I think that there are potentially ways
to uh conduct pilot programs that are
not not mandated or or voluntary um that
are self-funded yeah it's potential yeah
there there's potential for that and um
we would certainly welcome any any
efforts to reduce waste that's going to
disposal or is otherwise recovered
so okay any other questions
thank you so much thank you I call now
Sarah
silk from
wolfboro good
afternoon good afternoon thank you for
the opportunity to speak with you I have
since 1990 been in charge of a hazardous
waste for the town of wolfboro until
2002 at which time we built a permanent
site and um we have uh member towns of
Alton and
wolfboro and then we also accept waste
from anyone from away on a fee basis and
we also a facilitator for small quantity
generators we do a lot of interfacing
with Dees because people call
frequently deaths moving in moving out
they get these big large quantities and
most of the household hazardous waste
programs have a 10 gallon limit or 10
pounds 50 pounds whatever depending on
the size of the program and people
cannot always get rid of all of their
products in a safe
way I guess you all realize that it's
never good to send somebody away not
happy with something that will cost more
to pick up and clean up than it will be
to take safely so if you come to me and
you have 20 gallons if you're willing to
pay for it we will take it
my program takes anything through our
six days in wolfboro we have two
Satellite collections in Alton we are
only open when our wasti holler is there
our waste holler we get three-year
contracts and renewal we are jumping 15%
this year Lakes Region Planning
Commission their waste holler is jumping
40% we need help here people
and
while a 55 gallon drum for paint is not
as expensive as a 55 gallon drum of
pesticides for me to get rid of we have
more
paint John McDonald is my local rep who
lives down the street and I spoke with
him about this back in the spring he
also is Chairman of the budget committee
and goes over my portion of the budget
for our facility it's divided by between
the two member towns he agreed that you
know if we could find a way to get rid
of that which is a really big portion
and just for clarification we only take
latex because that's hazardous we I mean
excuse me I'm sorry we only take the oil
base because that's hazardous we don't
take the latex and as someone testified
previously the way to get rid to latex
in most communities is to add kitty
litter sand it goes into Solid Waste and
we pay by the ton to get rid of it we
have just increased the weight of it to
be disposed of but no one that I know of
local towns around me will take a liquid
paint product I believe although I I
don't know for certainty that it's
because the cans if they're crushed leak
someone comes whoever your waist toer is
whether it's waste management or
cassella they don't want this stuff
leaking out of their dumpster on to the
car behind them as they're taking it to
their eventual you know resting place if
I could find way to lessen my cost I
could serve people better for the things
that cost more I went to Vermont with
someone from Dees and with Vicky Davis
from Upper Valley Lake sopy Regional
planning to Vermont and we visited a
couple of sites in the spring the one in
Bur inton has an area where they take
latex paint
in they have people that open the cans
it's it's two people open the cans check
and see if the paint looks good they
have 55 gallon drums blue red green
whatever they have a 55 gallon vat at
the end that is all one particular color
it's it's not just down to like three
colors they add mde and everything else
they bottle it up into can
they sell it for $11 a
gallon it's a great way to use it up
it's very affordable for people Tim was
just speaking about
frugality and they have a waste toer
that comes and picks up the oilbased
paint and any of the latex paint that is
not
recyclable the program is through paint
care and Vermont as was testified
earlier and the thing is is that the
dollar or approximate a dollar whatever
the the little price on a gallon of
paint is that goes into the fund to help
take care of it and the manufacturers of
paint it's a product responsibility for
the
manufacturers I've
been doing this like I said since 1990
1990 the state of New Hampshire had
$200,000 for grant money to distribute
among all hazardous waste collections
that happen in a fiscal year 35 years
later
$200,000 we know I mean just forget the
people that just came because of the
pandemic to New Hampshire but we know
that since 1990 the population of the
state has grown exponentially and as it
grew people renovated people built new
people have increased the amount of
hazardous waste we have in our state but
we haven't increased a way to better
handle it with any assistance to the
towns
and this
isn't anything except like a little fee
like if you get rid of your batteries
you get rid of your tires if you don't
buy paint you don't you don't pay for it
and then the program is pretty much
self- sustaining I it's I've um listen
to our quarterly household hazard waste
site coordinators meetings I've listened
to people from paint care and they have
it sounds like voluminous reports that
they give back to the states to track
and I just would really
encourage your group to look into it
give us some serious
thought okay representative Murray thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
a question I just wanted to make sure I
heard you correctly in your testimony
you said that paint care will do some of
the leg work and the data of the
collection they have to do accounting
work and send it back to the state okay
and and not that it isn't a good idea
that somebody at the state level doesn't
yeah but no I I understand so there is
there is some additional reporting
communication going on a lot yes from
what I understand
yes any other representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question
um I'm very interested in this topic and
I heard you say that um your waste huler
fees have gone up
15% and I think you said somebody else's
are
40% my waste holler is clean
hobbers the first year of our three-year
contracts are always the most
expensive the most expensive we've had
since 202 was a 10% increase the first
year this year it's
15% on top of the 15% is another
percentage the second year and the third
year on top of all that you get a
recovery fee as well which during the
pandemic went as high as
19.5% we were lucky we had it in our
contract for
13 Lakes Region Planning Commission uses
trbi as their waste holler that Rose
40% just so there's no misunderstanding
we are build differently trbi Lakes
Region Planning Commission has eight
well seven or eight uh
collections they have a specific fee
for a site regardless of which one it is
if there's some kind of a threshold say
if it gets over this is arbitrary but
say it gets over 200 people on a day
then then the additional ones would be
more I pay because I have a Hazmat
building I pay only for full containers
that leave full 55 gallon drums full
Gaylords with 100 paint cans in it
whatever so I also have to pay over
$1,800 plus recovery fee just to get
them to my place it's very very
expensive wolfb is about 6,000 somewhat
people as does Alton and my budget is
about
92,000 to
$997,000 and we we don't waste
it sure it's it's just getting harder
because the stuff is dangerous
M indeed thank you okay any other
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming thank you very much for
allowing me to speak with you anyone
else wish to speak on this
no seeing none I'm going to close this
hearing uh well we've got the blue sheet
here and we've got five three people
four oh three people in favor of this
bill online online we have five in favor
one
opposed and I'm going to end close out
the
uh hearing for
hp504 okay so um we are done with our
business for this week for
today and
uh um I do want to let the committee
know that um I am I've scheduled uh
Tuesday February 13th next week for um
work session in the morning and for
public hearings on some bills and then
we'll also be a meeting Wednesday
February
14th also for Bill hearings and uh work
session in the afternoon so um that's
what's on the docket for next week and
with that I um say thank you all for
being attentive and asking good
questions and participating so have a
good rest of the evening thank
you oh and don't forget to get your
committee reports to me if you're
working on committee
reports
great